hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid heute ein
bisschen früher als sonst denn wir
gucken gleich gemeinsam auf die zweite
sommerpressekonferenz von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und Themen über die man da
sprechen kann gibt es genug die
parlamentarische Sommerpause läuft zwar
aber das heizungsgesetz ist noch nicht
beschlossen der russische Angriffskrieg
in der Ukraine geht weiter diskutiert
werden gerade das Elterngeld das
Ehegattensplitting ja und die AFD die
erreicht während all dessen im ZDF
Politbarometer erneut ein Rekordwert wie
äußert sich Olaf Scholz im Sommer 2023
zum ampelhof und zu den Themen die die
Bundesregierung aber auch die Menschen
in Deutschland bewegen wir gucken da
gleich live gemeinsam mit euch drauf und
ordnen das ganze ein mit meiner
zdf-kollegin und Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin Nicole Dietmann wenn ihr
fragen habt an Nicole oder generell zur
Pressekonferenz zum ampelhof dann
schreibt uns die wie immer gerne hier im
Chat oder per Mail an die eingeblendete
Adresse und da ist sie schon Nicole
schön dass du bei uns bist da Dankeschön
schön hier zu sein hallo Nicole wir sind
zwar in der parlamentarischen
Sommerpause Pause ist aber gerade nicht
so richtig zumindest in der Debatte was
für ein Bild gibt denn die
Ampelkoalition in diesem Sommer ab genau
wir sind in der Sommerpause aber wir
sind nicht in der Ampel streitpause du
hast es eben schon erwähnt dass GEG das
sogenannte heizungsgesetz da wurde in
den vergangenen Monaten viel gestritten
es ist jetzt noch nicht beschlossen weil
da noch Karlsruhe das
bundesverfassungsgerät Gericht
reingegrätscht ist da hatte man sich
aber zum Schluss geeinigt und damit die
große Hoffnung verbunden jetzt wieder
ein Bild der Geschlossenheit und
Harmonie und wichtiges Stichwort in der
Politik Handlungsfähigkeit nach außen zu
senden damit war schon am Wochenende
also quasi zwischen Ende vor Sommerpause
und beginnen Sommerpause war damit schon
wieder Schluss da kam nämlich dass das
Thema Elterngeld das Thema
Ehegattensplitting auf der SPD-Chef
laskingball hat eine Abschaffung des
ehegattens aufgebracht in der Diskussion
darüber wo man kürzen können wenn nicht
beim Elterngeld und darüber wird jetzt
diese Woche gestritten also sprich ähm
das Parlament geht jetzt in die
Sommerpause der Streit in der Ampel tut
es nicht
ja und wie dieser Streit in der Ampel
bei den Bürgern und Bürgerinnen da
draußen ankommt das können wir über das
ZDF Politbarometer checken das hat sich
mein Kollege Jonas Kapp mal für uns
angeguckt
im aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer sind nur
40% der Befragten zufrieden mit der
Arbeit der Ampelkoalition
54% finden sie macht ihre Arbeit
schlecht die Mehrheit denkt sie wird in
der laufenden Legislaturperiode nicht
auseinanderbrechen jedoch wird das
Verhältnis der drei Parteien als sehr
angespannt gesehen 74% bewerten es als
schlecht wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre käme die Kanzlerpartei SPD auf 17%
der Stimmen die Union auf
27%. die Grünen liegen bei 16%, die FDP
bei 7%, die AFD fährt erneut einen
Rekordwert ein und liegt bei 20%. die
Linke wäre mit 4% raus aus dem Bundestag
19% der Befragten machen die Grünen für
das Erstarken der AFD verantwortlich
eine deutliche Mehrheit von 44% sieht
aber alle Parteien in gleichem Maße in
der Schuld
ja
54% finden die Ampelkoalition macht ihre
Arbeit schlecht Nicole wie schätzt du
denn aus deiner Erfahrung heraus diese
Wert ein ist das normaler Wert der nach
eineinhalb Jahren
Koalition normal ist oder ist das schon
bedenklich
das ist schon niederschmetternder Wert
aus Sicht der Ampelkoalition die er eine
Fallhöhe selbst geschaffen hat in mit
der Überschrift die sie sich selbst
gegeben hat als fortschrittskoalition
und da ist noch viel Luft nach oben das
ist ein Wert der sicherlich diesen
Termin heute für Olaf Scholz bei dem er
sich von der Hauptstadt Presse befragen
lässt nicht gerade angenehm erscheinen
lässt die große Frage ist jetzt scholzt
er wie es hier mittlerweile im Berliner
Regierungsviertel heißt lässt er die
Fragen an sich abhören oder geht er
tatsächlich auf die Kritik ein ja und
diese Frage die Nicole gerade aufwirft
die gucken jetzt uns gleich mal an olaf
hat es nämlich angekommen wir klären
danach weiter eure Fragen jetzt gucken
wir erstmal auf den Livestream
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor allen
Dingen die Fotografinnen und Fotografen
wenn langsam ein paar Bilder im Kasten
sind wäre ich sehr dankbar wenn sie sich
setzen könnten
dass wir hier vorne einen freien Blick
haben und vielleicht auch der Rest im
Saal einen freien Blick auf uns
so ich würde jetzt wirklich gerne
anfangen ich wäre Ihnen dankbar wenn Sie
die Plätze einnehmen noch mal liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzlich
willkommen
in der Bundespressekonferenz wo heute
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zu Gast ist um
unsere Fragen zu beantworten herzlich
willkommen und ich begrüße natürlich
auch den regierungssprecher Steffen
Hebestreit der diesen Platz hier gut
kennt weil uns vermutlich auch einige
Leute in Fernsehsendern oder in
Livestreams zuschauen ein zwei Sätze zur
Bundespressekonferenz wir sind ein
Verein in dem sich Hauptstadt
Journalistinnen und Journalisten
organisiert haben um hier
Pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten die
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen Gelegenheit
geben sollen Fragen an Regierung
Opposition Wissenschaft Verbände zu
stellen die hier bei uns zu Gast sind
ein Hinweis noch vorab ich vermute es
wird relativ viele Fragen geben ich
versuche sie alle zu erfassen wenn ich
ihn zu nicke ist das ein gutes Zeichen
dass ich sie erkannt habe weil es viele
fragestellerinnen und schneller geben
wird bitte ich Sie sicher auf eine Frage
ein Thema zu begrenzen mit einer
Nachfrage die immer möglich ist wenn
jemand schon zwei oder drei Fragen in
seiner Frage verpackt nimmt das andere
gegeben gegebenenfalls die Gelegenheit
das finde ich nicht so fair nochmals
herzlich willkommen herr Scholz sie
haben das Wort
ja schönen Dank für die Einladung an
einem schönen Sommertag und die
Gelegenheit ein paar Worte zu sagen ich
will am Anfang für mich auf vier
Bemerkungen konzentrieren
erstens unverändert
mit unser ganzes Leben
beeinflusst von dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine es ist
Krieg in Europa nicht weit von
Deutschland entfernt das bewegt die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das muss alle die
Verantwortung haben in den Regierungen
Europas bewegen und entsprechend haben
wir auch gehandelt der russische
Angriffskrieg ist ich habe es im
Deutschen Bundestag letztes Jahr so
gesagt eine
Zeitenwende weil er die Verständigung
die wir über Jahrzehnte in Europa hatten
das mit Gewalt keine Grenzen verschoben
werden dürfen
aufgekündigt hat und mit größter
Brutalität versucht der russische
Präsident sich ein Teil des Territoriums
seines Nachbarlandes oder das ganze Land
anzueignen das können wir nicht
akzeptieren und auch nicht geschehen
lassen und deshalb haben wir daraus
Konsequenzen gezogen wir unterstützen
die Ukraine finanziell humanitär aber
auch mit Waffenlieferung damit sie sich
verteidigen kann die Integrität und
Unabhängigkeit ihres Landes sichern
das tun wir nicht alleine sondern
zusammen mit sehr vielen Freunden und
Verbündeten die das in gleicher Weise
machen trotzdem ist es auch so dass nach
den USA Deutschland jetzt das Land ist
das die größte Unterstützung auch in
militärischer Hinsicht was
Waffenlieferung betrifft für die Ukraine
bereitstellt sie wissen aus den
Entscheidungen die wir getroffen haben
dass das auch für die nächsten Jahre
sichergestellt ist wir haben einmal
ausgerechnet dass seit Beginn des
Krieges bis etwa 27 ist möglicherweise
es 17 Milliarden Euro sein werden die
wir aufwenden alleine für
Waffenlieferungen die aus Deutschland
oder von Deutschland finanziert für die
Ukraine stattfinden es ist gut dass das
auch eine Rolle gespielt hat bei den
Beratung die jetzt in Vilnius im Rahmen
der NATO stattgefunden haben die
natürlich kein Schlusspunkt sind sondern
Zwischenpunkt in einer Welt die sich so
sehr verändert aber die doch die
richtigen Konsequenzen gezogen hatten
erstens ist es so dass wir was uns alle
verpflichten mindestens zwei Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung für Verteidigung
aufzuwenden und anders als bei den
früheren Beschlüssen kann man davon
ausgehen dass das ein kurzer Zeit auch
von allen Ländern erreicht werden wird
mit
Konsequenzen für die Fähigkeit des
Bündnisses ihre auf seine Aufgaben
wahrzunehmen und im übrigen ist es so
dass wir uns mehr konzentrieren auf
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung anders
als in früheren Jahren und das gleiche
gilt natürlich dann auch für uns selber
hier in Deutschland wir haben uns
entschieden dass wir diese zwei Prozent
für die Verteidigung für die Bundeswehr
aufwenden wollen nächstes Jahr werden
wir das aus Haushaltsmitteln und dem
Sondervermögen das erste Mal erreichen
und ich wiederhole hier was ich bei
vielen Gelegenheiten gesagt haben das
wird auch so bleiben auch wenn das
Sondervermögen aufgebraucht ist das
zweite Bemerkung
wir haben
darüber die Aufgabe nicht vergessen
Deutschland zu modernisieren und die
notwendigen Innovationen auf den Weg zu
bringen damit wir wirtschaftlich stark
bleiben
moderne Technologien in unserem Land
haben auf die wir zurückgreifen können
und die den Grundlagen unseres
Wohlstandes und unserer Rolle in der
Welt auch sein können und gleichzeitig
ist zu schaffen den menschengemachten
Klimawandel aufzuhalten so bitter es ist
die Notwendigkeit ganz schnell zu
handeln und in kürzester Zeit um einen
kalten Winter und eine langanhaltende
Wirtschaftskrise zu vermeiden Terminals
an den norddeutschen Küsten zu errichten
hat auch das Tempo dieser Veränderung
noch einmal erheblich beschleunigt und
wie ich es wahrgenommen habe auch den
Konsens größer gemacht dass das jetzt
mit großer Geschwindigkeit sein muss wir
haben alle Gesetze auf den Weg gebracht
damit wir 2030 80 Prozent unseres Stroms
aus erneuerbaren Energien bekommen
können ob das eine Windkraft auf hoher
See an Land oder Solar Energie ist um
das Stromnetz auszubauen nur so lange es
immer wieder zu verzögern gekommen ist
haben wir jetzt Gesetze auf den Weg
gebracht damit das schnell geht wir
werden damit das 24 50 Stunden 7 Tage
die Woche Strom gibt sicherstellen dass
das Wasserstoff ready Gaskraftwerke gibt
wir haben jetzt die Entscheidung
getroffen dafür zu sorgen dass wir auch
ein wasserstoffnetz bekommen da werden
dieses und Anfang nächsten Jahres die
notwendigen Entscheidung getroffen und
wir haben alle Vorbereitungen dafür
getroffen dass das Netz der
lade-infrastruktur mitwachsen kann mit
der wachsenden E-Mobilität da ist unser
Ziel wie Sie wissen 15 Millionen
Elektrofahrzeuge 2030 das hat
Konsequenzen für das Netz und seine
Fähigkeiten im Hinblick auf der
Stromnetz haben wir auch alles umgedreht
und jetzt gesagt es müssen die Planung
bereits jetzt aufgenommen werden damit
wir 2045
einen Stromnetz haben das dann ja noch
viel mehr Strom produziert für die
künftige Wirtschaft und damit das nicht
wieder so verzögert wird werden die
Entscheidung jetzt getroffen sie kennen
die Pläne der entsprechenden Netze
Betreiber und das werden wir jetzt alles
auf den Weg bringen also große
Innovationen im Energiesektor wir sehen
das auch in der Industrie wo jetzt
Entscheidung getroffen werden für
klimaneutrale Stahlwerke für neue
Produktionsverfahren in der Chemie
Milliarden hunderte Milliarden
Investitionen in der Automobilindustrie
und haben das verknüpft mit einem
massiven Ausbau des öffentlichen
Verkehrs der
innovationsinvestition für die Bahn und
den Dingen die damit verbunden sind dass
Deutschland Ticket ist dafür ein gutes
Zeichen ich sehe aber auch dass die
modernen Investitionen die wir für
unsere Zukunft brauchen jetzt in
Deutschland stattfinden wir haben die
gute Chance dass Deutschland ein
Standort vielleicht der große Standorte
der Halbleiterindustrie in Europa wird
mit den Entscheidungen für wolfspeed im
Saarland der Entscheidung von Infineon
in Dresden und der jetzt auch bekannt
gewordene Entscheidung von Intel in
Magdeburg die größte Direktinvestition
in Europa seit aller Zeit die man
betrachten kann das glaube ich ist in
seiner Dimension noch gar nicht
verstanden worden aber natürlich ein
ganz bemerkenswertes Ereignis genauso
wie die Investition die jetzt
stattfinden bei der Errichtung neuer
batterie-fabriken zum Beispiel alles das
was wir für die Elektromobilität
brauchen es ist also so dass in unserem
Land Fahrt aufgenommen worden ist und
das Tempo jetzt immer mehr zunimmt dass
wir aber auch brauchen damit wir
tatsächlich unsere Zielsetzung erreichen
und immer eine Volkswirtschaft mit guten
Arbeitsplätzen bleiben
damit das so bleiben kann haben wir die
wahrscheinlich wichtigste
Zukunftsentscheidung schon getroffen im
Bundestag und in der
vorbereitenden Gesetzgebungsarbeit der
Bundesregierung mit dem Fachkräfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz ist das was die
meisten Ökonomen und Ökonomen als große
Sorge für die Zukunft Deutschlands
beschreiben angegriffen und aufgegriffen
nämlich die Gefahr des Fachkräftemangels
wir werden als Volkswirtschaft die
notwendigen Arbeitskräfte nach
Deutschland bekommen so dass das
Wachstum nicht behindert wird durch ein
Mangel an Arbeitskräften das ist wichtig
für unseren Sozialstaat wichtig für
unsere wirtschaftliche Zukunft und diese
notwendige ziemlich Ideologie freie
Entscheidung haben wir getroffen
dritte Bemerkung aus meiner Sicht ist es
ganz zentral dass wir den Zusammenhalt
unserer Gesellschaft stärken auch dort
sind sehr weitreichende Entscheidungen
in kurzer Zeit getroffen worden die dazu
einen wichtigen Beitrag leisten ich will
exemplarisch nur anführen die Anhebung
des Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro im letzten
Jahr wie angekündigt jetzt sind wir
wieder im normalerhöhungsverfahren aber
das ist ein substanzieller Schritt der 6
Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern eine
ganz dramatische Gehaltserhöhung
ermöglicht hat wir haben steuerliche
Entlastung gerade für klein und mittlere
Einkommen auf den Weg gebracht zum
Beispiel wird heute das könnten der
Rentenbeitrag komplett von der Steuer
abgezogen neben den Tabellen Entlastung
ist das eine ganz wichtige Leistung
gewesen wir haben den Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer die wenig verdienen und hat
arbeiten und trotzdem unter 2000 Euro
brutto bleiben die Beiträge zur
Sozialversicherung reduziert auch ein
ganz wichtiger Schritt für den
Zusammenhalt und gleichzeitig viele
Reformen auf den Weg gebracht und
noch vor die genau in dieser Sache
wichtig sind zum Beispiel die Anhebung
der Erwerbsminderungsrenten die letztes
Jahr stattgefunden hat oder die jetzt
geplante
Schaffung eines stabilen lerntenniveaus
über das Jahr 25 hinaus auf lange lange
Sicht ein Vorhaben dieser Regierung das
jetzt praktisch uns die nächste Zeit
begleiten wird und glaube ich vielen
Bürgern und Bürgern Sicherheit gibt
gerade den jungen Leuten die mit 17 die
Schule verlassen und wissen da sind 50
Jahre Arbeit die sie vor sich haben da
wollen sie ja wissen ob das dann auch
alles aufgeht wie man sich das vorstellt
also auch an Entscheidungen die ich ganz
wichtig finde in diesem Zusammenhang
eine Reformen neben vielen anderen will
ich noch herausheben die wir vor uns
haben und bei der wir große Schritte
schon gegangen sind das ist die
Schaffung der Kindergrundsicherung wir
wollen dass es keine Kinderarmut in
Deutschland mehr gibt mit der Anhebung
des Kindergeldes für das erste zweite
und dritte Kind auf 250 € mit dem
Kinderzuschlag von auch bis zu 250 Euro
für Familien die wenig Geld verdienen
ist der Grundlage geschaffen und jetzt
kommt der nächste Schritt bis Ende
August um eine vollständige
Kindergrundsicherung in Deutschland zu
etablieren damit Kinder nicht aufgrund
sich Sicherung und Bürger Geld
angewiesen sind wie ich finde ein großer
auch moralischer Fortschritt für unser
Land den wir uns hier vorgenommen haben
vierte Bemerkung
wir haben es wirklich hingekriegt dass
nach vielen Jahren in denen wir
notgedrungen von der
Regel des Grundgesetzes dass wir nur
eine ganz geringe Neuverschuldung haben
sollen für den Bundeshaushalt abgewichen
sind nach vielen Jahren jetzt eine Zeit
in der wir wieder zu diesem normalen
Prinzip zurückkehren das glaube ich
haben viele nicht erwartet und zwar mit
berechtigter Skepsis wir haben hunderte
Milliarden Euro ausgegeben
kreditfinanziert um die folgende
corona-pandemie zu bewältigen die
notwendigen gesundheitsinvestitionen zu
tätigen aber auch sicher zu stellen dass
wir es schaffen dass wir wirtschaftlich
durch diese Zeit kommt dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das sozial
unterstützt werden wo das notwendig ist
wir haben noch mal so viel Geld
mobilisiert um die Konsequenzen des
russischen Angriffskrieges auf unsere
Volkswirtschaft abzufedern mit sehr
teuren Subventionen von Energiepreisen
damit die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
zurechtkommen und vieles andere wir
haben auch das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr auf den Weg gebracht aber
alles zusammen ist natürlich eine
Sondersituation gewesen und dass wir das
künftige Wachstum unserer
Volkswirtschaft jetzt organisieren
können ohne dass wir an einem solchen
Maße Verschuldung organisieren müssen
das finde ich ist ein richtiger Schritt
wir sind bei dem Haushalt wieder auf der
richtigen Umlaufbahn und das finde ich
ein gutes Zeichen in dem Sinne freue ich
mich auf ihre vielen
und es gibt viele Fragen vielen Dank
dafür dann kommen wir zu ihren Fragen
das haben sich eben gerade wie ist so
oft dass alle gleichzeitig gemeldet ob
ich alle gesehen habe kann ich nicht
versprechen im Zweifel machen Sie noch
mal auf sich aufmerksam die erste Frage
hat Frau Münstermann
ja Herr Bundeskanzler wenn in Umfragen
in Deutschland die AFD relativ stabil
vor der Kanzlerpartei der
Regierungspartei SPD legt ist etwas ins
Rutschen geraten inwieweit trägt ihre
Regierung in die beitragen sie als
Regierungschef die Verantwortung dafür
und was wollen Sie konkret dagegen
unternehmen ich habe mich mit dem
Auftreten und der starken
rechtspopulistischer Parteien ja schon
sehr lange auseinandergesetzt für mich
war das nicht der erste Moment aber der
wichtigste Moment als ich feststellen
musste 2001 das in Hamburg eine
rechtspopulistische Partei aus dem Stand
fast 19% der Stimmen bekommen hatte die
seinerzeit die schildpartei und dann
habe ich mich umgeguckt und gesehen dass
schon seit Jahrzehnten in Dänemark und
Norwegen dort rechts populistische
Parteien stark waren das ist in den
Niederlanden der Fall war in Österreich
mittlerweile wissen wir auch dass das in
Schweden und Finnland der Fall ist und
bei uns in Deutschland
und deshalb müssen wir uns fragen woran
liegt das denn mit dem Blick von außen
in der Welt würde man sagen das sind die
Länder die die wenigsten Probleme von
allen haben da lebt man ganz gut es gibt
Vollbeschäftigung es gibt einen starken
Sozialstaat und die Zukunft ist auch
nicht schlecht was die Volkswirtschaften
betrifft meine These ist es nicht daran
dass sich eben doch nicht so viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger so sicher sind
wie die Zukunft sein wird gar nicht
jetzt sondern 10 20 und 30 Jahren und
deshalb ist das was wir an
Modernisierungsprogramm auf den Weg
gebracht haben das was wir an
Innovationen anstoßen wollen für unsere
Volkswirtschaft wichtig weil sie ja
immer auch die Botschaft mit vermitteln
es wird gut ausgehen für jeden Einzelnen
und jede einzelne von uns die zweite
Einsicht die ich daraus für mich gezogen
habe ist dass wir
die Tatsache dass unsere
Lebensmodelle sich unterschiedlich
gestalten die Tatsache deswegen viele
neue Bildungswege haben aber auch ganz
unterschiedliche Bildungs- und
Berufskarrieren
neu bewerten müssen in dem Sinne dass es
nicht das eine gibt was richtig ist und
alles andere aussticht das heißt die
Durchlässigkeit die wir geschaffen haben
für viele Kinder aus Familien wo niemand
studiert hat es selber einmal zu tun und
auch Karrieren in bestimmten Berufen zu
erreichen darf nicht dazu führen dass
wir nicht genau verstehen dass
eigentlich unsere Volkswirtschaft davon
lebt das ganz viele sich gut entscheiden
Handwerkerin zu werden Krankenpfleger zu
sein das auch welche in einem großen
Logistikunternehmen im Lager tätig sind
dass das funktioniert in den
Einzelhandelsgeschäften und ich finde
diese Einsicht die ich versucht habe mit
dem Wort Respekt zu beschreiben ist
zentral dafür dass das funktioniert und
das dritte was wir brauchen in unseren
Gesellschaften und eben auch bei uns in
Deutschland ist Gelassenheit
im Hinblick auf das Miteinander dass da
eben sehr unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
sind wo man gerne lebt wie man gerne
lebt und dass das eben zusammen ganz gut
funktionieren kann wenn man nicht
jeweils dem anderen mitteilt dass es
genau nach dem eigenen nach der eigenen
Fassung zu geben hätte sondern dass
jeder sich seine eigene wählen soll und
darf und das glaube ich würde helfen und
muss auch helfen und das ist auch das
was wir mit unserer Politik verfolgen
deshalb will ich auch auf ihre
Ausgangsfrage sehr klar sagen ich bin
ganz zuversichtlich dass die AFD bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl nicht viel
anders abschneiden wird als bei der
letzten
wir bleiben am gleichen
mikrowellenfischer
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler ich würde
sie gerne zu den Turbulenzen in der
Koalition der letzten Monate Fragen
über das heizungsgesetz hat die Ampel ja
seit März gestritten ich würde gerne
wissen ob sie heute im Rückblick sagen
würden dass sie irgendetwas anders
machen würden nicht was die Inhalte
angeht sondern dass die Organisation des
Entscheidungsprozesses als Bundeskanzler
angeht würden sie haben sie da Fehler
gemacht
aus denen sie für die Zukunft lernen
oder würden Sie sagen alles richtig
gemacht mache ich beim nächsten Mal
wieder so
es ist ja kein Geheimnis dass da so laut
diskutiert worden ist gefällt weder mir
noch irgendwem sonst insofern ist die
Frage woher kommt das und wahrscheinlich
hilft auch dort ein struktureller Blick
denn tatsächlich ist es doch so dass
bestimmte Dinge die mit dem
innovations-tempo dass wir uns für
Deutschland vorgenommen haben und dass
wir auch tatsächlich auf den Weg
gebracht haben wie sie meine
eingangsschilderung entnehmen konnten
auch verbunden ist dass viele viele
Dinge das erste mal diskutiert werden wo
in den Debatten davor immer nur
Ausgangsposition existiert haben also
die einen sagen es muss immer so gehen
und die anderen sagen es geht gar nicht
und dazwischen ist aber doch die
Wirklichkeit ich glaube wir brauchen
nicht nur als Regierung sowieso aber
auch als Gesellschaft an Verständnis
dafür dass Abwägung das Kompromisse das
zwischen verschiedenen Positionen etwas
hinzubekommen was das Ziel nicht aus den
Augen verliert auch gute und vernünftige
Politik ist dafür werbe ich sehr
dass wir diesen Pragmatismus innerlich
als Gesellschaft aber selbstverständlich
auch als Regierung haben bin aber froh
dass wir im Ergebnis jetzt eine sehr
gute Lösung haben mit den beiden
strengen die wir jetzt miteinander
verknüpft haben nämlich der wärmeplanung
die die Kommunen in Deutschland vor sich
haben und viele ja auch schon angefangen
haben und den Gesetz das sicherstellt
dass wir um die Mitte dieses Jahr zehn
CO2-neutral heizen können indem wir die
beiden nicht nur nebeneinander sein
lassen sondern die wärmeplanung zu einem
wichtigen
voraussetzungsinstrument gemacht haben
für die ganz konkreten Entscheidungen
die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor Ort
zu treffen haben deshalb also muss man
da glaube ich sich einmal klar machen
dass der Konsens dass der Kompromiss
dass das fünfte gerade sein lassen ein
guter Weg ist der Deutschland noch vorne
bringt
eine Nachfrage der Bundeskanzler ihr
Parteivorsitzender Lars Klingbeil hat
den konflikteam in der Koalition jetzt
kurz vor der Sommerpause ja noch ein
weiteres hinzugefügt mit seiner
Forderung nach einer Abschaffung des
ehegattens splittings da würde ich gerne
wissen ob sie den Zeitpunkt für diesen
Vorschlag für gut und richtig halten und
wie stehen sie selbst dazu sie haben
sich ja gestern Abend dazu geäußert ist
diese Äußerung so zu verstehen dass sie
sich eine Abschaffung für hohe Einkommen
vorstellen können für Normalverdiener
aber nicht
mir ist ganz wichtig dass wir uns an das
dem orientieren bei dem was wir als
Regierung machen was wir in unseren
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben da
kommen natürlich immer mal Sachen
dazwischen und das ist jetzt leicht
gesagt für eine ziemlich ungeheure Sache
zum Beispiel den fruchtbaren
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
das hat ja viele Konsequenzen für alles
Mögliche was wir zu entscheiden haben
aber trotzdem ist das erstmal der
Maßstab da haben wir auch noch ganz
ordentlich was vor obwohl ich glaube
dass wir was ja auch richtig ist den
größten die größten Herausforderungen
bewältigt haben die aus den ehrgeizigen
Vorhaben der Koalitionen entsprungen
sind und
deshalb habe ich nur darauf hingewiesen
dass es ein Missverständnis ist
zu interpretieren das jetzt die meisten
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bei den
Diskussionen die ja nicht neu sind über
das Ehegattensplitting sich selbst
betroffen fühlen müssen es geht ja
tatsächlich bei den Vorschlägen die in
den letzten Jahren gemacht worden sind
von verschiedenen Organisationen der
Institutionen immer um diejenigen die
viele hunderttausend Euro verdienen und
das darauf hinweisend habe ich dann noch
gesagt im übrigen haben wir ja noch ein
Vorhaben an dem der Finanzminister sitzt
nämlich die Frage wie wir die
Besteuerung für Frauen und Männer die
verheiratet sind gerechter machen können
indem wir verhindern dass Frauen viel zu
steuern zahlen durch das heutige
steuerklassensystem das geht aber
natürlich nur wenn wir mit der modernen
Technik vorankommen und da ist es
manchmal ganz schwer in Deutschland aber
erst dann
die nächste Frage hat die Kollegin in
der Reihe davor sie nee sie genau
ich bin Julie von Johanna
Nachrichtenagentur Südkorea
der Raum in Indopazifik scheint in der
deutschen und europäischen
Sicherheitspolitik Gewichte Tiger zu
werden die AP 4 Staaten wurden zum
NATO-Gipfel eingeladen und in der neuen
china-strategie steht auch Sicherheit in
Europa Atlantik und Indopazifik sind
stark verbunden finden Sie auch die NATO
muss die Zusammenarbeit mit den ap4
statt Staaten verstärken und hat die
Bundesregierung mit Blick auf China und
Nordkorea konkrete Pläne die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Partnern
Indopazifik auszubauen
schönen Dank für die Frage ich finde es
sehr gut dass wir wenn ich das bei
dieser Gelegenheit sagen darf jetzt sehr
wichtige weitreichende Dokumente
erarbeitet haben als Regierung die auch
handlungsleitend sein werden für das was
wir machen die nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie wie ich finde ein
großer Schritt vorwärts weil Deutschland
hatte bisher keine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie sondern immer nur
vom Verteidigungsministerium
verantwortete weißbücher und die
china-strategie ist auch erstellt worden
passt ganz gut zu der die wir schon
haben für den endop Pazifik und
natürlich hat das Konsequenzen die NATO
ist ein transatlantisches Bündnis das
will sie auch bleiben und ich habe
vorhin ja schon berichtet dass Landes
und Bündnis Verteidigung wieder eine
große Priorität bekommen haben aber wir
können ja nicht naiv sein sondern müssen
die Welt als Ganzes in den Blick nehmen
und deshalb ist die gute Zusammenarbeit
mit den Staaten die wir auch eingeladen
haben zum Beispiel zu dem NATO-Gipfel
wichtig für unsere Sicherheit gemeinsam
und das werden wir auch weiter im Blick
haben das ist jetzt nicht zu Ende mit
dem gipfelius und ich war ja auch selber
zum Beispiel in Japan in Südkorea in
Indonesien nicht hier bin in engem
Gespräch mit dem australischen in der
seelischen Regierungschefs und mit
vielen anderen in der ganzen Region
die nächste Frage hat Herr Rinke und der
Mitte ist es das richtige Mikro
und jetzt danke Herr Bundeskanzler ich
wollte auch noch mal nach der
china-strategie fragen weil viele
Unternehmen sich jetzt fragen was diese
china-strategie in der ja nicht alles
jetzt schon fein
ausdifferenziert wurde eigentlich für
sie bedeutet also einige Sachen sind ja
offen geblieben
etwa die Frage ob mit dieser China
Strategie eine Investition wie die von
cosco in einer
Betreibergesellschaft im Hamburger Hafen
eigentlich noch möglich gewesen wäre ob
es eine Huawei Beteiligung am 5g Netz
geben könnte und so weiter also können
sie das ein bisschen ausdifferenzieren
was jetzt auf die Firmen wirklich
zukommt oder weil lassen sie eigentlich
diese Ausgestaltung jetzt dem
Wirtschaftsministerium danke
ich finde die schienenstrategie sagt das
meiste selber aus aber trotzdem
vielleicht dieser Hinweis mein die
Unternehmen in Deutschland Handeln ja
längst im Einklang mit dem was wir jetzt
auch hier geschrieben haben mein
Eindruck ist viele Unternehmen werden
weiter kräftig in China investieren
werden nach China exportieren werden
auch Waren und Dienstleistungen aus
China beziehen aber gleichzeitig im
Sinne dessen dass wir die Riss gegen
nennen die Möglichkeiten nutzen die sich
ihnen ergeben auch anders so direkt
Investitionen zu tätigen auch in anderen
asiatischen Ländern zum Beispiel
anderswo Lieferketten aufzubauen und
anderswo
auch
waren hinten und Maschinen und was wir
in Deutsch aus Deutschland so
exportieren hin zu exportieren insofern
sehe ich eher einen großen Einklang
zwischen dem auch veränderten
Investitionsstrategien der Unternehmen
und dem was wir als Regierung
aufgeschrieben haben
darf ich kurz nachfragen ich wollte das
ja etwas konkreter haben wenn sie sagen
könnten was heißt das zum Beispiel für
investitionsprüfungen im Ausland oder
hier in dem Fall in China das war ja
große Streitpunkt weil die Unternehmen
fürchten dass da eine Bürokratie wollen
Bälle auf sie zu rollt sie kennen ja
schon die Festlegung die wir bei den G7
getroffen haben zu diesem Thema was wir
auch in der EU diskutieren das ist ja
doch ein es gibt nicht darum jetzt alle
Investitionen die im Ausland getätigt
werden jetzt nun eine staatlichen
Kontrolle zum unterwerfen Deutschland
ist eine
globale Volkswirtschaft die mit der
ganzen Welt verbunden ist das ist unser
Geschäftsmodell dass die Unternehmen
ohne dass sie der Regierung jeden Tag
bescheid sagen überall wirtschaftlich
tätig sind das würde uns auch
überfordern solche Ämter hätten wir gar
nicht mit denen wir diese Aufgaben
bewältigen können dass wir genau
hingucken wollen wenn es um Fragen geht
die für militärische Sicherheit und für
Sicherheit insgesamt von Bedeutung sind
das ist vielleicht so selbstverständlich
aber wir haben das jetzt auch
aufgeschrieben
Frau Dunz hat die nächste Frage
auch wieder das falsche es ist heute
schlecht zu sehen Herr Bundeskanzler ich
möchte gerne noch mal auf die AFD
eingehen sie haben in ihrer Reaktion
gesagt dass sie ja über die
Sozialpolitik Menschen mit niedrigeren
Einkommen besser stellen nun ist ja
Umfragen zu Folge ein großer Rückhalt
für die AFD im reicheren Bürgertum den
sie eine
Normalisierung rechten Gedankengut in
Deutschland war und wenn sie auf zwei 25
blicken zur Bundestagswahl und sagen die
werden nicht besser als 21 abschneiden
was rechnen Sie für Ostdeutschland im
nächsten Jahr aus muss man dann mit
alparteien Koalitionen auf eine
vielleicht stärkste Partei nämlich der
AFD der reagieren
überall in allen 16 Ländern und
Deutschland insgesamt sind die
demokratischen Parteien die einander
trotz politischen Wettbewerb ja ganz gut
läuft immer mit Respekt behandeln und
ihre Anhängerschaften die große Mehrheit
das dürfen wir glaube ich nicht beiseite
lassen und deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir das immer wieder im Blick haben
wenn wir darüber diskutieren welche
Konsequenzen wir aus solchen
Wahlergebnissen wie wir sie in letzter
Zeit gesehen haben ziehen wollen für
mich heißt das dass man Politik machen
muss bei der die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
für sich genügend Gründe haben an eine
gute Zukunft zu glauben ich bin nicht
wiederholen dass ich eben gesagt habe
aber das ist das was ich für
zentralhalte das geht nicht von einem
Tag auf den anderen und es scheint ja
auch ein größeres Problem zu sein wenn
das nicht nur bei uns passiert sondern
auch in Ländern die so ähnlich sind wie
wir und von daher ist das für mich ganz
zentral
und
was war glaube ich nicht was übersehen
habe die Normalisierung
danke dass Sie das noch mal sagen dann
wollte ich nämlich sagen nein ich sehe
keine solche Normalisierung
ich habe eine Nachfrage
sie haben gesagt man soll dem anderen
nicht mitteilen dass es nach der eigenen
Fasson gehen sollte haben Sie ein
Beispiel dafür wer macht das meinen sie
die Grünen oder wem halten sie sowas vor
ich halte das niemanden vor aber ich
glaube ihr seid so fleißig und habt das
alles schon mal aufgeschrieben
ich glaube dass es in einer Politik in
der man eng miteinander zusammenarbeitet
und zwar über Parteigrenzen und
regierungsgrenzen hinweg nicht so ist
dass man immer irgendwie
mit dem Finger auf irgendwelchen zeigen
müsste
mit der nächsten Frage geht es weiter
auf der von uns ausgesehen linken Seite
hier vorne sie genau sie sind der mich
anschaut hatten sie keine Frage ach so
dann dann war das ein Missverständnis
dann gehen wir weiter zu entsafeberg
ja guten Tag Bundeskanzler von der
Zeitung Telegraf Frage freundliche Frage
aus den Niederlanden
in dieser Woche hat der
Ministerpräsident markgritte seinen
Rücktritt angekündigt also Regierung ist
zurückgetreten er selbst wird auch die
Politik verlassen wie schauen Sie wie
schauen die Bundesregierung zurück auf
diese 13 Jahre mit Margarete sozusagen
aus wichtiger Partner auch an der Seite
von Deutschland also sie wissen
er hat auch die landesstreitkräfte die
Brigaden unter der deutschen Kommando
stellen lassen
ja erst vor allem auch wegen der
illegale Migration ist ja zurückgetreten
also hatte diesen Rücktritt eingereicht
und die haben in Deutschland dieses
Problem auch also manche Kommunen sind
natürlich ziemlich überfordert mit dem
was gerade auch wieder stattfindet die
Migration hatten sie seit 2015
vielleicht ein bisschen einordnen und
auch Margarete zurückblicken
zunächst mal Deutschland und die
Niederlande haben exzellente Beziehung
miteinander ich erinnere mich noch an
die jetzt kurz zurückliegenden
regierungskonsultation die wir
lockere angenehme Unterbrechung eines
30-stündigen Koalitionsausschusses
wahrgenommen haben
das sind gute Beziehungen auch in allen
Ebenen wo wir miteinander sprechen und
das hat dann natürlich auch was mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten zu tun insofern
blicke ich auf die Arbeit der letzten
Jahre und zwar nicht nur jetzt als
Kanzler sondern auch schon davor
durchaus gerne zurück das sind gute
Beziehung unserer Länder und ich hoffe
das bleibt auch so was die Frage
betrifft das Umgangs mit Migration hat
das ja viele eben viele Schichten ich
bin sehr dankbar dafür dass wir jetzt
nach vielen vielen Jahren ganz offenbar
das erste Mal ist wirklich schaffen
könnten in Europa einen
solidaritätsmechanismus zu verabreden
das ist auch das Verdienst des
gemeinsamen Gehirns der niederländischen
und der deutschen Regierung aber da
arbeiten wir jetzt alle daran dass das
jetzt auch tatsächlich kommt dass das
gewissermaß dass die Ernte in die in die
Steuer gefahren wird und das
funktioniert
wir haben für Deutschland
ja
eingebettet in einem fortschrittlichen
Umgang mit den Anforderungen die unsere
Arbeitsmarkt hat was Zuwanderung
betrifft trotzdem klargestellt dass wir
reguläre Migration mit all den
Möglichkeiten die wir haben
einhegnen wollen durch unsere
Handlungsfähigkeit durch die Gesetze
durch die Strukturen die wir haben und
die Verständigung die ich
den Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsidenten zu diesem Thema in
Deutschland vorgeschlagen habe und die
wir gemeinsam beschlossen haben setzen
wird Stück für Stück um was jetzt eher
zum Beispiel gemeinsam alles sichere
Herkunftsländer betrifft was die anderen
Fragen zu
Verbesserung der verwaltungseffizienz
und auch rechtliche Strukturen in diesem
Zusammenhang betrifft und dann ist es
natürlich so dass wir eine klare
Vorstellung davon haben welche
welchen Schritt wir jetzt gehen müssen
um
das Unbehagen dass sich bei dem ein oder
anderen einstellt dass wenn wir eine
Entscheidung haben dass jemand
zurückgehen muss das schwer
durchzusetzen ist
verändert werden kann die
migrationspartnerschaften die wir
vorhaben
haben ja das Ziel dass wir mit Ländern
vereinbaren dass diejenigen die
gut passend zu unserem Arbeitsmarkt und
die ist eine Möglichkeit gibt in
Deutschland Fuß zu fassen
einerseits das leichter können als das
heute der Fall ist im Interesse auch
unserer Volkswirtschaft dass wir
andererseits aber vereinbaren dass die
Rückführung derjenigen die nicht bleiben
können dann kooperativ besser und
effizienter gelingt und das ist das was
wir uns vorgenommen haben damit alle
wissen wir tun das was in unserer Macht
steht um gewissermaßen das ganze
Themenfeld in einer gut ausbalancierten
Weise zu verhandeln und das ist ja eine
Aufgabe die groß ist weil sie in allen
Ländern vorkommt auch in anderen
Kontinenten und deshalb darf mir Sie
sicher auch nicht so einfach vorstellen
vielleicht mal kurz danach frage wenn
sie gestalten also in Holland in meinem
Land ist die Regierung darüber
zerbrochene beendet seine politische
Karriere in Deutschland hört man
manchmal von auch führ Politiker aus dem
Osten
aus Brandenburg oder aus Sachsen das zum
Beispiel auch wegen der illegale
Migration ist
Grenzen Grenzkontrollen so einführen
wollen wie wie stehen Sie dazu ist das
eine
Notmaßnahme die die man überlegen könnte
man sieht auch gerade in diesen Ländern
ist auch die AFD man hat schon
angesprochen ziemlich stark also
anscheinend sind die Bürger etwas naja
wie muss man das sagen
etwas
beunruhigt durch die Situation
ich habe ja schon gesagt es gehört dazu
dass wir allen sagen können dass wir die
irreguläre Migration steuern können dass
wir die Kontrolle über das Geschehen
haben und dass wir auch sicherstellen
können dass diejenigen die nicht bleiben
dürfen auch wieder zurückkehren und so
organisieren wir unseren Politik ich
habe eingangs bereits gelobt den
solidaritätsmechanismus den wir in
Europa vereinbaren wollen der ist ein
großer Schritt nach vorne weil er ja mit
einer Sache haben eine Sache bewegt
nämlich die Frage was passiert
eigentlich
angesichts der Tatsache dass die
Außengrenze von Deutschland und die
Außengrenze der Niederlande nicht die
Außengrenze der Niederlande und die von
Deutschland ist sondern das sind
EU-Außengrenzen also wir sind auch auf
Solidarität im Umgang miteinander
angewiesen und diese Erkenntnis scheint
sich durchgesetzt zu haben da setzen wir
natürlich drauf dass das der Fall ist
und ansonsten werden wir immer flexibel
pragmatisch handeln sie wissen dass wir
Kontrollen
haben die stärker sind an der
deutsch-österreichischen Grenze wir
hatten sie zeitweise auch an anderen
Grenzen wir haben im
rückwärtigen Bereich
verschiedenen verstärkte
polizeipräsenzen organisiert damit wir
das Geschehen gut
im Blick behalten können und wir haben
mit unseren Nachbarländern also mit der
Schweiz mit der Tschechien und mit Polen
konkrete Vereinbarung wie wir
kooperieren damit das im Blick damit das
gelingt und dann müssen wir gucken ob
das reicht oder nicht natürlich sind
die offenen Grenzen innerhalb Europas
eine der ganz großen Errungenschaften
der Europäischen Union und wie gesagt
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir den
europäischen solidaritätsmechanismus
bekommen
ja vielen Dank Maximilian Bärbel in der
Zeitung
[Musik]
zu irritiert gucke durch die
Übertragungstechnik durch sie immer
nicht von da wo Sie sitzen
vielen Dank in den vergangenen Wochen
gab es ja zahlreiche Berichte über
massive Gewaltausbrüche in deutschen
Schwimmbädern also es betrifft das ganze
Land in Berlin will man jetzt mit
Ausweiskontrollen und Videoüberwachung
darauf reagieren was glauben Sie denn
woran es liegt dass ich viele Menschen
nicht mehr sicher fühlen können in
deutschen Schwimmbädern nein auch sie
wie Frau Faser das mehr Polizei oder das
Polizei in Schwimmbäder gehen muss und
wann waren Sie eigentlich das letzte Mal
im Freibad
also im Freibad schwimmen war ich
zuletzt in Rahlstedt großlohe das ist
also über 40 Jahre her ich bin aber
schon in Freibädern gewesen zum Beispiel
in meinem Wahlkreis und habe mit dem
Bürgern und Bürgern dort geredet das ist
den letzten den vorletzten Sommer zum
Beispiel sehr intensiv so gewesen und
glaube auch dass es ein Stück
Lebensqualität ist dass wir diese
Möglichkeiten in Deutschland haben das
gehört zur kommunalen Daseinsvorsorge
das sagt sich so aber aus meiner Sicht
ist das ganz wichtig und deshalb muss
man auch reagieren wenn solche Vorfälle
da sind darf man nicht einfach sagen das
Aktien zu Kenntnis nehmen dann muss man
auch Handeln zum Beispiel mit Polizei
eine Nachfrage danke aus der Union hieß
es jetzt zuletzt dass das auch also
nicht nur aber auch mit
integrationsdefiziten zu tun hat diese
Tumulte wie sehen Sie das würden sie da
zustimmen oder sehen Sie es anders
verhält sich nicht so wie unsere Regeln
sind und das ist dann etwas was wir
zurecht beklagen müssen und deshalb
nochmal es ist völlig richtig wenn
daraus die Konsequenz gezogen wird jetzt
auch Polizei einzusetzen wir müssen ja
immer hingehen und dafür sorgen dass
ganz schnell klar wird dass wir als
Staat das nicht dulden
in der Hoffnung dass es sich dann dass
das dann nicht dauerhaft so bleibt aber
dass man dann sofort und auch mit der
ganzen Kraft die wir haben zeigt wir
dürfen das nicht das halte ich für
zentral
die nächste Frage wir gehen zurück in
die vordere Mitte zu Frau Rumänien
hallo hallo ich habe Fragen zu Ukraine
und zwar nach Videos sprechen alle über
viele über Sicherheitsgarantien würden
sie tatsächlich das was ihr sieben
beschlossen hat auch so nennen als neue
Sicherheitsgarantien oder ist das
eigentlich die Fortsetzung dessen der
Kiefer zu Selbstverteidigung der Ukraine
und unterstützen sie den Vorschlag auch
von Alexander weil das Russland nach dem
Kriegsende die Reparationen aus den
Einnahmen
von Öl und gasexporten zahlt
ich habe ja schon ein bisschen Bezug
genommen auf die wirklich guten
Beschlüsse der NATO in Vilnius und
daneben aber am Ort hat ja dann auch
eine Zusammenkunft der G7 Staaten
stattgefunden mit
einer Vereinbarung zur
Sicherheitspartnerschaft wenn man das so
nennen will und diese Vereinbarung halte
ich für sehr weitreichend denn sie
beinhaltet ja zwei Dinge im Kern einmal
die Aussage dass wir jetzt während des
Krieges die Ukraine weiter mit den
notwendigen Waffen und
Verteidigungsmöglichkeiten unterstützen
werden und dass wir das auch danach tun
werden das ist ja sehr zentral und das
wäre uns miteinander austauschen wenn
eine bedrohliche Lage in der Zeit danach
entsteht das sind ja die Dinge die man
da wiederfinden kann
warum ist das zentral ich habe das vor
kurzem aber so wahrgenommen der
Verteidigungsetat das was die Ukraine
gegenwärtig für Verteidigung aufwendet
ist wohl jetzt so groß wie der Etat des
ganzen Landes oder der Haushalt der
Ukraine vor dem Krieg das müsste man
sich jetzt mal auf deutsche Dimension
hochgerechnet vorstellen was das
bedeuten würde und das ist klar dass die
Volkswirtschaft der Ukraine das alleine
nicht tragen kann
wie das alles sein wird nach dem Krieg
das glaube ich
zu spekulieren verbietet sich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt da finde ich muss man
auch konzentriert sein auf das was jetzt
ansteht und das ist dass wir all die
Kraft mobilisieren die notwendig ist
damit wir auch so lange wie es
erforderlich ist die Ukraine
unterstützen können wenn Sie unser
Haushaltssituation betrachten und dann
wissen dass wir für die nächsten Jahre
weitere milliardenschwere Unterstützung
der Ukraine für ihre
Verteidigungsfähigkeit vorgesehen haben
dann können Sie sich vorstellen wie das
in anderen Ländern aussieht wenn ich das
alle gemeinsam auch tun und deshalb ist
ein solches commitment dass sich dort in
der Vereinbarung findet doch sehr
weitreichend gute Nacht
nehme ich dass sie nicht von Sicherheit
garantieren sprechen und mich würde
interessieren jetzt angesichts dessen
dass wir jetzt im zweiten Jahr der
Krieges in der Ukraine sind und sie in
zweiten Jahre als Bundeskanzler wie
urlaubsreif sind sie eigentlich
ich freue mich darauf dass ich in Urlaub
fahren kann aber es ist nicht so dass
wenn es jetzt nicht möglich wäre ich das
nicht hinkriegte aber schön ist wenn es
möglich ist auch mal kurz weg zu sein
die nächste Frage ich schau ein bisschen
irritiert weil ich bin nicht die einzige
die hier so ein Pfeifen hört oder hören
das auch andere ich habe keine Ahnung wo
es herkommt ob so einem Stuhl kommt ob
es aus einer Kamera kommt aber wenn das
abzustellen wäre wäre ich ganz dankbar
okay es scheint gefunden zu sein vielen
Dank die nächste Frage in der Reihe
dahinter Herr Schuler
vom Nachrichtenportal News wir haben ja
Integrationsprobleme in Freibädern schon
angesprochen jetzt hat die
ampelregierung beim neuen
Aufenthaltsrecht in der Einleitung dass
die Wendung Steuerung und Begrenzung der
Zuwanderung das Wort Begrenzung
gestrichen welche Botschaft geht von
dieser Streichung des Wortes Begrenzung
aus
die Regierung
will die irreguläre Migration begrenzen
und gleichzeitig wollen wir dafür sorgen
dass Deutschland Volkswirtschaft gut
durch die Zeit bekommt und wir im Rahmen
der regulären Fachkräfte und
Arbeitskräfte zu Wanderung in den
nächsten Jahren
all die Babyboomer die jetzt in Rente
gehen können und Rente gehen werden
ersetzen können damit das läuft im Laden
Deutschland und das ist etwas was
gleichzeitig stattfindet deshalb ist das
glaube ich auch das richtige Paar dass
man im Kopf haben muss Begrenzung der
irregulären Migration und gleichzeitig
dafür Sorge tragen dass wir eine
reguläre
Zuwanderung nach Deutschland haben die
dafür sorgt dass das mit der Rente
weiter klappt dass unser Sozialstaat
funktioniert dass unsere
Wirtschaftskraft aufrecht erhalten
bleiben dass das eine gute Sache ist
haben wir in den letzten Jahren gemerkt
denn tatsächlich ist uns ja für die Zeit
in der wir jetzt leben vor zehn und 20
Jahren vorher gesagt worden dass wir
viel weniger Beschäftigte hätten und
dass wir viel weniger Einwohner hätten
tatsächlich ist die Einwohnerzahl
gewachsen und die Zahl der Beschäftigten
auch wir haben die höchste Zahl von
Erwerbstätigen in der Geschichte unsere
Republik und das ist glaube ich schon
etwas ganz Besonderes wenn man sich das
klar macht und durch diese
kluge Kombination von zwei
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven kommen
wir auch zu einem Erfolg für unser Land
das spricht für mich jetzt eher dafür
dass Begriffspaar so beizubehalten statt
die Begrenzung zu streichen
ihre Urteile nicht abnehmen aber meins
ist dass das alles super zusammen passt
die nächste Frage Herr Dörner in der
gleichen Reihe
Herr Bundeskanzler in ihren einführen
und Bemerkungen hatten sie die Bedeutung
der mindestlohnerhöhung für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt betont
gleichzeitig hatten sie gesagt nach dem
Vorschlag der mindestlohnkommission sie
seien ein bisschen enttäuscht schließen
sie aus dass sie doch auch noch mal
politisch in das Thema Mindestlohn
Eingreifen
Last klingball hat er auch noch einen
Vorschlag in diese Richtung gemacht
erst mal es war von mir angekündigt dass
ich eine einmalige Intervention per
Gesetz vornehmen werde wenn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mich zum Kanzler
wählen und das habe ich gemacht letztes
Jahr mit einer erheblichen Anhebung des
Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro und wir haben
gleichzeitig angekündigt dass wir dann
wieder zum Normalverfahren zurückkehren
werden dass die mindestlohnkommissionen
darüber entscheidet das hat sie jetzt
gemacht und zwar erhöhungsschritte für
das nächste und
übernächste Jahr festgelegt
für mich gehört eigentlich zur guten
Tradition dieses Landes dass die
Sozialpartnerschaft
also entschuldigung aber
irgendwo muss hier entweder bei einem
Handy ein Pfeifen rauskommen
jetzt sind alle ganz stille und
derjenige oder diejenige wird erwischt
es ist ein merkwürdiges Pfeifen
Klingelton auf Jingle Bell eingestellt
hat der ist es
bitte noch mal alle auf die Handys
schauen achso
ansonsten einfach draußen vor die Tür
legen solange es wartet da auf Sie
also ich glaube das ist jetzt kein
Cyberangriff
aber jetzt im Ernst können Sie
vielleicht kurz mit dem Handy rausgehen
und das klären dann können wir hier
weitermachen
lieber Kollege können Sie einfach kurz
rausgehen und das klären dann können wir
weitermachen sie können auch gerne
wieder reinkommen das wäre jetzt glaube
ich die beste Lösung damit sie
weitergehen kann
das Weihnachten
so aber diese
deshalb
wünsche ich mir dass wir diese Tradition
auch in der mindestlohnkommission weiter
fliegen und das heißt dass man die
Möglichkeit zu Mehrheitsentscheidung hat
aber alles dafür tut das ist nie dazu
kommt sondern dass man sich verständigt
und ich setzt darauf dass das gelingt
Frau Lehmann in der Reihe davor hat die
nächste Frage ich hatte eine Frage zum
industriestrompreis wie ihnen der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister die Gewerkschaften
Industrie und auch der niedersächsische
Ministerpräsident fordern also ein
subventionierten Strompreis für die
Industrie die im
internationalen Wettbewerb steht können
Sie noch mal erläutern ob und warum die
warum sie das skeptisch sind und welche
alternativen Möglichkeiten sie sehen
damit solche Unternehmen am Montag
werden weiterhin in Deutschland zu
investieren zunächst mal ist die Debatte
ja nicht schlecht ist wir thematisieren
dass wir
billige Strompreise für Deutschland
brauchen insbesondere die Wirtschaft
Leute aber auch für die auch für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker und viele
andere
das ist auch eine Perspektive die wir in
Deutschland erreichen können denn der
Windstrom und der Strom aus der
erneuerbaren Energien der im Norden und
Osten Deutschlands produziert wird macht
jetzt schon möglich das subventionsfrei
sehr preiswerte Strom
liefert zu sagen gemacht werden können
für Unternehmen das ist mit den
Industrieansiedlung die jetzt in letzter
Zeit stattgefunden haben immer verbunden
gewesen und da hat nicht der Staat
geholfen sondern das ist etwas was sich
aus der Preislage vor Ort ergibt würden
wir jeweils nur
nach Regionen die Strompreise ermitteln
werden sie im Norden und Osten
Deutschlands jetzt schon sehr gering was
uns gegenwärtig umtreibt ist dass wir
so sehr in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht
vorangekommen sind beim Ausbau der
Übertragungsnetz
Strukturen dass wir richtig
Verzögerungen haben und das führt jetzt
zu der etwas absurden Situation dass wir
Geld ausgeben um
diejenigen die billigen Windstrom
produzieren wollen dafür zu bezahlen
dass es nicht tun im Norden und Osten
und dass jemand der den gekauft hat
geliefert wird in dem im Süden
Deutschlands nochmal
Maschinen angeworfen werden und mit Gas
und Kohlestrom produziert wird zweimal
geben wir Geld aus was wir nicht müssten
hätten wir die Leitung schon gebaut
darum ist es schon ganz wichtig dass wir
dieses Jahr nächstes Jahr tausende
Kilometer haben und wenn ich sage wir
verfolgen das Ziel und zwar nicht nur so
wie früher sondern real dass wir 2030 80
Prozent des Stroms aus erneuerbaren
Quellen haben und das Stromnetz
entsprechend ertüchtigt haben dann wird
das ja zu einem flächendecken Sinken der
stromproduktionskosten in Deutschland
führen wir müssen jetzt darauf aufpassen
das nicht durch die
Regulierungsvorschriften aus Brüssel
oder die Regulierung die wir selber
haben die billigen Produktionskosten
nicht durchschlagen können also das
schlimmste Szenario wäre der Strompreis
richtete sich nach einem immer noch
laufenden Gaskraftwerk das permanent
Strom produziert obwohl eigentlich der
Strom zu billigen Windstrom und
solarstrompreisen produziert wird zu 90
oder
95%. das jetzt nur als gegriffen
bezahlen aber man muss das einmal so
aussprechen damit wir wissen dass wir
auch eine regelaufgabe haben dass die
billigen perspektivisch und zwar schnell
perspektivisch billigeren
Produktionskosten für Strom in
Deutschland auch auf die Preise
durchschlagen das muss unsere Aufgabe
sein und deshalb sind wir dabei genau
das alles zu machen in diesem
Zusammenhang muss man dann gucken was
lässt uns europäische Regulierung
überhaupt machen
das ist nicht so viel wenn ich das mal
sagen darf aber gucken darf man ja auf
alle Fälle ist es immer möglich zu
gucken kann man möglicherweise
entsprechend unser Beschlüsse die wir
schon gefasst haben Unternehmen
ermöglichen dass sie ganz konkrete
preiswertere Lieferverträge aus
erneuerbarem Strom für sich abschließen
und damit für sich das Sichern das ist
dann ja eine solche Art von verbilligten
Strompreis kann man darüber nachdenken
wie wir sicherer machen können dass wenn
jetzt jemand sagt ich will jetzt hier
ansiedeln und mir sagt jemand zu dass
der Strompreis dann billig sein wird
dass das auch klappt also da gibt es
viele Richtung und Facetten in die man
nachdenken muss und
weil wir jetzt ja doch so interessante
Diskussion über einzelne Gesetze hatten
ich glaube bevor wir ein
Gesetzesvorschlag machen diskutieren wir
das ganz ordentlich verstehen alle
Facetten in jeder Hinsicht
Herren Kinski hat die nächste Frage
der Bundeskanzler auf die Frage nach dem
Ehegattensplitting und der Finanzpolitik
haben sie auf den Koalitionsvertrag
verwiesen gesagt dass man sich sinngemäß
daran halte was dort steht andererseits
haben sie eine zeitenwände ausgerufen
und die kostet ja auch viele hunderte
Milliarden Euro muss man eigentlich
sagen warum umfasst diese zeitenwände
eigentlich nach ihrem Verständnis in
dieser Legislaturperiode nicht die
Finanzpolitik und wenn ich mal den
Sozialdemokrat in ihnen Fragen darf
nicht den Bundeskanzler was wäre denn
eigentlich ihre Vorstellung mal ganz
unabhängig von ihren Koalitionspartnern
an welcher Stelle man in der
Finanzpolitik vielleicht etwas verändern
sollte
zunächst mal haben wir eine Zeitenwende
bei Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hat
und das die Verständigung aufgekündigt
hat dass man Grenzen nicht mit Gewalt
verschiebt darauf reagieren wir unsere
Politik ist nicht die zeitenwände die
Zeitenwende ist diese Bedrohung für die
Friedens und Sicherheitsarchitektur
Europas die von dem aggressiven
Verhalten Russlands ausgeht und deshalb
müssen wir auf Dauer eine stärkere
Bundeswehr haben mit zwei Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung auf die dauerhaft
setzen kann auch wenn das Sondervermögen
ausgegeben ist in
der zweiten Hälfte der 20er Jahre und
sind in den 30er Jahren und das gleiche
gilt für die Frage der der ganzen
Sicherheitsarchitektur drumherum die wir
mit unseren Verbündeten der NATO zu
entwickeln
bei der
Finanzpolitik ist es so dass wir ja doch
schon sehr viele weitreichende
Entscheidungen getroffen haben und auch
einige noch vorhaben die sich übrigens
aus dem Koalitionsvertrag ergeben zum
Beispiel dass wir was tun wollen für
Startups z.B dass wir sicherstellen
wollen dass Investitionen in
Energieeffizienz besonders
mutig Vorankommen das glaube ich ist
ganz ganz zentral und deshalb sehe ich
schon dass wir aufbauend auf das was wir
in den letzten Jahren entwickelt haben
da war ich ja auch schon Finanzminister
jetzt gute Perspektiven haben genau
solche
wachstumsfördernden Aspekte mit
einzubauen
also wir haben die Vermögen in
Deutschland die weit auseinander gehen
und wir haben hunderte Milliarden von
zusätzlichen Kosten und die
finanzpolitische Maßnahme die Sie jetzt
hier quasi herausgeben ist eine
Finanzierung von Start-ups ich meine
gibt es nicht eine große Idee die sie
haben ihre Partei zum Beispiel möchte
eine einmalige Vermögensabgabe in vielen
der spd-wahlprogramme auch in ihren
standen dass man in der Steuerpolitik
was machen will denn Spitzensteuersatz
zum Beispiel anheben will es gibt immer
noch eine Programmatik dass man in der
Erbschaftssteuer einer Vermögenssteuer
was machen will was sind ihre Haltung zu
diesem Thema das Wahlprogramm dass die
SPD aufgestellt hat und mit dem ich zur
Bundestagswahl angetreten ist spricht
meiner Überzeugung und auf der Basis
habe ich einen sehr guten
Koalitionsvertrag verhandelt
die nächste die jeder eine Nachfrage es
tut mir leid ihre pinski vielleicht
versucht jemand anders für sie noch mal
hier jung hätte die nächste Frage
zum Thema Streu Munition und Streubomben
kommen und die ächtigung nach Artikel 21
Absatz 2 des Oslo Übereinkommens das
Deutschland ja unterzeichnet hat bemüht
sich jeder Vertragsstaat Zitat nach
besten Kräften Staaten die nicht
Vertragsparteien dieses Übereinkommen
sind vom Einsatz von Streumunition
abzubringen und habe ich bisher
nirgendwo von Versuchen ihrerseits
gegenüber Russland der Ukraine und der
USA gelesen diese vom Einsatz von
streumunion abzubringen gab es diese
Bemühungen nicht oder wir haben sie
diese
völkerrechtliche Vertragsverpflichtung
nach besten Kräften wahrgenommen
Deutschland hat die von Ihnen zitierte
Konvention unter die unterzeichnet wir
haben keine bestreuung werden sie auch
nicht beschaffen und auch nicht
einsetzen und bei vielen internationalen
Gelegenheiten haben Vertreter der
Bundesrepublik viele dafür von zu
überzeugen versucht dass sie
entsprechende Zeichnung dieser
Konventionen vornehmen
die USA haben sie nicht unterzeichnet
darauf haben sie hingewiesen Russland
Ukraine auch nicht und deshalb habe ihm
wir ja sehr klar gesagt dass wir die
souveräne Entscheidung anderer Staaten
nicht zu kommentieren haben aber sie
sind ja vertraglich das verpflichtet
andere Staaten davon abzubringen weil
das ein universeller Ansatz ist diese
diese Konvention der US-Präsident beiden
hat passieren angesagt dass er sich mit
den mit den Verbündeten abgestimmt hat
zu dieser Lieferung hat Herr beiden mit
ihnen darüber gesprochen und wie haben
Sie ihn ähm versucht davon abzubringen
wozu sie verpflichtet sind wir haben
bereits darauf hingewiesen wohnen und
welcher Stelle wir das in den letzten
Jahren immer wieder gemacht haben als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
selbstverständlich hat die USA uns nicht
überrascht wir haben das nicht über ihr
Medium sondern direkt von den USA
erfahren welche Entscheidung die
getroffen haben und wiederhole noch mal
in dieser Situation hat die
amerikanische Regierung eine
Entscheidung getroffen die nicht unsere
ist aber die sie souver än getroffen hat
übrigens mit dem Hinweis dass sie das
deshalb macht weil sie sonst nicht
ausreichend Munition zur Verfügung
stellen kann aber ich will ergänzen noch
mal sagen für mich ist diese Konvention
von großer Bedeutung es geht ja gar
nicht um die Waffe in ihrer Wirkung im
Kriegseinsatz
wenn alle Waffen die wir liefern haben
fruchtbare Zerstörung zur Folge wenn sie
ihre Ziele treffen
sondern es geht darum dass nicht nach
dem Krieg und außerhalb der
Kriegsparteien von zufällig
herumliegender Munition andere bedroht
werden dass das ein Thema ist verstehen
wir in Deutschland ja nur zu gut
wer wie ich in Brandenburg lebt weiß das
ist dort und nicht nur in Brandenburg
übrigens Wälder gibt in denen immer noch
Munitionen aus den letzten Tagen des
Zweiten Weltkrieges sich befindet und
wenn dann Brände ausbrechen ist das eine
große Herausforderung überall in
Deutschland wo Bomben niedergegangen
sind gibt es jetzt noch so viele
Jahrzehnte nach dem Ende des Zweiten
Weltkrieges immer wieder Bombenalarm und
deshalb ist es schon ein sehr
berechtigtes Anliegen dass wir mit
dieser Konvention verfolgen und dem
fühle ich mich auch verpflichtet
wir gehen jetzt mit den Fragen auf die
von uns ausgesehen rechte Seite hinten
zu Frau Wilke
Herr Bundeskanzler in der vergangenen
Woche wurde auch über die Sterbehilfe
diskutiert zwar Anträge wurden
erreichten keine Mehrheit
ja wie zufrieden können Sie damit sein
also es waren interfraktionelle Anträge
aber trotzdem wie zufrieden können Sie
damit sein
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
spricht immerhin von einer gewissen
rechts Unsicherheit die ist jetzt gebe
und sie selbst noch nicht abgestimmt
warum eigentlich danke
ich habe nicht abgestimmt weil ich nicht
abstimmen konnte weil ich an einem
anderen Veranstaltung war die sehr lange
vorher geplant war und dort eine
jemanden geehrt habe der den deutschen
Nationalpreis bekommen hat das fand ich
richtig habe mich aber erkundigt ob es
auf meine Stimme angekommen wäre dann
hätte ich die Veranstaltung verlassen
müssen das war aber wie Sie wissen nicht
der Fall denn keiner der beiden
Vorschläge die dort am Ende zur
Abstimmung standen deine Wert bekommen
und keiner war auch nicht dran an einer
Mehrheit
wir haben jetzt die Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die gilt
und solange der Gesetzgeber nicht durch
Veränderung des Gesetzes die umsetzt
muss das unmittelbar im Handeln der
Bürgern und Bürger und von denjenigen
die Verantwortung in diesem Bereichen
haben und tätig sind umgesetzt werden
dass wir natürlich schöner und besser
wenn das durch Gesetzesbeschluss erfolgt
wäre als wie es jetzt der Fall ist aber
an der Wirksamkeit an der an der
Klarheit der entscheidungs-bundes
Verfassungsgerichts kann ja kein Zweifel
bestehen jetzt werden solange der
Bundestag ist nicht doch noch schafft
eine Entscheidung zu treffen
die Gerichte
in den praktischen Einzelfällen die
Klarheit noch mal unterstreichen müssen
das ist bedauerlich das finde ich gar
nicht anders sagen aber das ist eben
auch eine Frage bei der ich mich bewusst
öffentlich zurückgehalten habe weil es
als Gewissensentscheidung der
Abgeordneten zu treffen war und auch
wenn ich selbst dazu auch eine eigene
Meinung habe das ist trotzdem so dass
ich finde das ist dann auch Respekt vor
dem Parlament sich da ein bisschen
zurückhaltend
die nächste Frage hat Herr kreuzfeld die
gleiche Reihe wesentlich weiterfahren
ja vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben ich wollte nur zum GEG
zurückkommen sie haben das ja eben als
guten Kompromiss gelobt für den
Koalitionsfrieden mag das stimmen fürs
Klima eher nicht in der Kompromiss
bedeutet jetzt erst im Vergleich zum
Entwurf aus dem Kabinett Entschuldigung
im Öl und Gasheizung in vielen Orten 5
Jahre länger eingebaut werden dürfen als
bisher geplant da ist meine Frage wieso
haben Sie eigentlich als klimakanzler
nicht mehr für den Entwurf aus ihrem
Kabinett gekämpft und wie wollen Sie
angesichts dieser großen Verbesserung
die es da gegeben hat die Klimaziele für
das Jahr 2030 im Gebäudesektor überhaupt
noch erreichen
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage weil sie mir
eine Gelegenheit gibt
ihn zu widersprechen
und trotzdem ist es ganz wichtig dass
Sie das fragen weil sie vielleicht ja
doch konkret bezugnehmen zu dem was ich
vorher hier schon versucht habe zu sagen
das Problem ist nicht
dass man da nicht verschiedene Meinung
haben kann das Problem ist dass sie so
ohne Absicht einen Weg dazwischen zu
finden aufeinander prallen und das gilt
ja nicht nur für Leute die dann
irgendwie Gesetze machen das geht ja für
uns als Gesellschaft insgesamt
meine Überzeugung ist wer zum Beispiel
Klimapolitik machen will muss sich
zutrauen dass jeder einzelne gesetzliche
Regelung in einer Volksabstimmung eine
Mehrheit fände
das muss der Ehrgeiz sein wir haben
keine Volksabstimmung in unserer
Verfassung und da bin ich auch der
Meinung sollte es bei bleiben weil wir
eine andere
Tradition haben aber ich will sehr klar
sagen das muss immer das sein dass man
mitdenkt und dann ist es doch okay zu
sagen dass jemand der Angst hat ob er
sich die nächste Investition leisten
kann ein Haus hat das vielleicht in den
letzten Jahren im Wert gesunken ist und
noch viele
Hypotheken drauf liegen
dass der oder diejenige das Gefühl hat
mitgenommen zu werden dabei zu sein und
diese Delegation von politischen
Meinungsbildung die ja im ganzen Volk
stattfinden müssen damit sie gut
funktionieren auf irgendeine Instanz die
das entscheidet und dann
ja rücksichtslos durchzieht die
funktioniert nicht das ist ein Fehler
das will ich ganz ausdrücklich sagen das
ist etwas was ich für eine falsche
Politik halte und darum werbe ich sehr
dafür dass man auch mal Fünfe gerade
sein lässt
aber gleichzeitig ambitioniert die
Klimaziele verforcht und wir sind da ja
sehr ehrgeizig Deutschland als
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
will 2045 klimaneutral Wirtschaften das
ist glaube ich in der Dimension an
industrieller und ökonomischer
Modernisierung bestenfalls mit dem zu
vergleichen was in der zweiten
Industrialisierung Deutschlands Ende des
19 Jahrhunderts stattgefunden hat da
werden unglaubliche milliardenschwere
Investitionen nötig neueste Technologien
müssen in verschiedensten Feldern in der
Industrie in der Wirtschaft in unserer
Energieerzeugung eingesetzt werden auch
bei der Mobilität und beim Heizen eine
Rolle spielen und da werden auch viele
unterschiedliche Technologien zum Tragen
kommen manche vielleicht noch große
Karriere machen auf die wir jetzt gar
nicht so kommen aber dass wir uns auf
den Weg machen dass wir nicht uns darauf
beschränken wie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten zu oft Ziele zu formulieren
und wenn es drängt wird noch größere
Ziele zu formulieren aber auf dem
Zwischenschritt nicht genug zu tun
dass wir das überwunden haben das ist
der eigentliche große Fortschritt den
wir jetzt haben
nicht ganz verstanden gerade wenn Sie
jetzt das Ziel so betonen und wie groß
die Aufgabe sind dass man zwischen
Schritte braucht wie wollen Sie denn
diesen Zwischenschritt jetzt erreichen
wenn weiterhin so viele Öl und
Gasheizung eingebaut werden dürfen das
habe ich noch nicht verstanden die
allermeisten Bürgerinnen und Bürger
werden sich ja jetzt auch durch diese
Debatte angeregt überlegen was für sie
eine gute Entscheidung ist und natürlich
werden die Preise für fossile Energien
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten
wahrscheinlich steigen wir haben jetzt
Europa wurde in den letzten Jahren um
nur ein Beispiel zu nennen von 180
Milliarden Kubikmeter russischem Gas
beliefert davon kommen jetzt nur noch
ganz kleine Teile an und in Deutschland
gar nicht mehr das heißt wir kaufen
unseren Gast woanders das ja aber auch
nicht in rauer Menge zur Verfügung steht
und stand und das im Kopf haben ist
jeder und jede gut beraten zu sagen es
können schon sein dass dadurch dass
überall auf der Welt eine Nachfrage ist
die größer ist als das was als als als
das Angebot oder zumindest da Druck
drauf macht das ist besser ist sich bei
seiner nächsten anstehenden Entscheidung
daran zu orientieren was auch billiger
sein wird und das ist natürlich eine der
vielen Varianten mit erneuerbaren
Energien ich bin aber sehr froh dass wir
die beiden parallelen Stränge
wärmeplanung und Heizung also Gebäude
Energie jetzt zusammengeführt haben
unter einen Zusammenhang hergestellt
haben zum Beispiel ist in Deutschland
das Potenzial von tiefen Geothermie
völlig und der ausgenutzt als ich
zusammen mit Frau Schwesig in Schwerin
eine solche Anlage eingeweiht habe für
das Fernwärmenetz von Schwerin habe ich
parallel erfahren dass
Ende der 80er Jahre in Mecklenburg und
Vorpommern sehr viele
vorgesehene tiefen Geothermie Bohrung
für das Fernwärmenetz damals vorgesehen
waren die dann wegen des billigen Gases
alle nicht vollzogen worden sind aber
sowohl dort als auch in Brandenburg und
weiten Teilen Ostdeutschlands im weiten
Teilen im Westen Deutschlands gibt es
gute Voraussetzungen und heute haben wir
auch noch viel mehr Geodaten zum
Beispiel darüber wo wir jetzt auch
beschließen wir wie die Nächte leichter
verfügbaren auffindbar machen können und
wir haben moderne Technik mit
Technikum rauszufinden ob die Bohrung
wohl erfolgreich wäre da wird also mehr
passieren als wir gegenwärtig im Kopf
haben Solarthermie kommt ja zu Unrecht
nicht mehr in den ganzen Berichten vor
ist aber auch eine Möglichkeit es geht
ja nicht nur um die Wärmepumpe wenn wir
über unsere Handlungsmöglichkeiten reden
und da könnte man jetzt noch viele viele
weitere Beispiele anfügen dass wir das
jetzt alles herstellen ist wichtig und
natürlich
wird jetzt die Debatte dazu führen dass
viele Kommunen sagen wir wollen unser
Fernwärmenetz ausbauen und dann ist ja
die gute Konsequenz dass sich
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ob das nun
Vermieter sind oder ein und zwei
familienhausbesitzer daran orientieren
können und sagen okay ich weiß in drei
Jahren in vier Jahren habe ich eine
Anschlussmöglichkeit also treffe ich
meine Investitionsentscheidung in
Hinblick darauf und das wird auch dazu
führen dass wahrscheinlich die Effizienz
und die Geschwindigkeit mit der uns das
gelingt größer wird als wenn wir diese
Verbundenheit nicht hergestellt werden
die nächste Frage in der gleichen Reihe
die Kollegen die Kollegin neben ihnen
dran
danke
Stream nämlich vorsichtig
zu handeln sich mit seinen Freunden und
Verbündeten abzustimmen keine
Alleingänge zu machen
und immer genau zu überlegen ist das
jetzt der richtige Schritt auf diese
Weise sind wir jetzt nach den USA der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
und trotzdem gibt es eine überwiegende
Zustimmung bei den Bürgern und Bürgern
für dieses Vorgehen und zwar auch bei
denjenigen die sich manchmal etwas mehr
wünschen und bei denjenigen die sich
weniger wünschen oder das eigentlich
falsch finden weil sie sich immer darauf
verlassen können dass wir eine
sorgfältig abgewogene Entscheidung
treffen und wissen dass es hier um eine
ganz ganz große Herausforderung geht
denn das findet ja wirklich in
unmittelbarster Nähe zu Deutschland
durch den russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine ein Krieg in Europa statt
zwischen dem Land mit dem größten
Territorium in Europa Russland und dem
Land mit dem zweitgrößten Territorium in
Europa der Ukraine und deshalb ist
glaube ich die Art und Weise wie wir das
machen die Grundlage dafür dass wir auf
ausreichend Zustimmung unter den Bürgern
und Bürgern rechnen kann
dann der Kollege dein Leben ja vielen
Dank
schwedische Rundfunk also wir wollen in
Naturland ja
aber wir haben eine
Vereinbarung mit der Türkei so wie wir
sagte die wollen
Erdogan und Türkei ein Mitglieder ein EU
bleiben sowas was denkst du was denken
Sie an das wollen sie schweren Hilfe
ich unterstütze den NATO-Beitritt der
Ukraine
können Sie nachlesen in den Beschlüssen
der NATO
aber ich unterstütze den NATO-Beitritt
Schwedens und
das wird hoffentlich jetzt auch zeitnah
erfolgen ich habe immer auch bei dem
türkischen Präsidenten dafür geworben
und ich finde sehr gut dass jetzt
unmittelbar vor dem Gipfel eine
Vereinbarung stattgefunden hat zwischen
Schweden und der Türkei und ich glaube
dass das
am Ende auch den Weg öffnen wird dazu
dass das jetzt passiert der türkische
Präsident hat gesagt dass er sich das so
im Oktober vorstellt und das nehme ich
jetzt mal so was die und ich bin da auch
sehr zuversichtlich ich habe keine
Zeichen dafür dass das jetzt sich
hinziehen wird oder sowas
und alle Voraussetzungen erfüllt und es
wird unsere gemeinsame Sicherheit
stärken und zwar auch sehr schön dass
der schwedische Ministerpräsident schon
in unserer Runde sitzen konnten weil wir
ja diese Entscheidung
ausgesprochen haben aber wurde es gut
mit Türkei
ich habe bei der im Vorfeld des letzten
Europäischen Rates dafür geworben dass
wir dort eine Entscheidung treffen
die Kommission aufzufordern
einen Bericht über den Stand unserer
Beziehung zu geben in der Hoffnung dass
wir daraus ein Aufschlag machen können
für
neue bessere oder verbesserte und weiter
verbesserte Beziehung zwischen der EU
und der Türkei da geht es aber um viele
konkrete Einzelfragen und das ist auch
sehr wahrgenommen worden als ein gutes
Zeichen dass die EU hier ein Interesse
hat und man Wunsch ist dass wir das auch
hinbekommen ich habe viele Gespräche
geführt auch mit vielen die
dort in Vilnius anwesend waren um jetzt
dazu beizutragen dass wir eine gute
Entwicklung auch konkret in der Region
haben wenn es um Türkei und Griechenland
geht zum Beispiel und auch danach sieht
es aus
die nächste Frage vorne der Mitte hat
Herr Delfs entscheiden Sie sich fürs
linke oder rechte nicht interessiert
Bundeskanzler sie sind ja Gemeinde
bekannt zu alt sein sehr eher kühler an
der artisch geprägter
Politiker kann man ja auch heute wieder
bewundern aber da gab es ja kürzlich
diese Szene in Falkensee wo sie ja doch
sehr emotional reagiert haben auf diese
pro Putin
Fans und
meine Frage wäre also erstmal dieser
emotionale Ausbruch von ihnen der der
dann folgte der ist ja sogar
international viral gegangen ich glaube
das war so so Hashtag Schulz und fire
dieses ist da ähm ist das unter kenne
ich viele Leute die sagen Mensch der
Scholz der hat ja doch Emotionen und ist
ja lebendig und sagt mal was er denkt
meine Frage wäre war das jetzt der wahre
Schulz wenn Sie also diesen Leuten sagen
ja ihr müsst erstmal ein bisschen Mensch
verstanden eure Hirne kriegen und also
eine ernstgemeinte Frage heißt das auch
sie haben im Grunde genommen aufgegeben
diese diese Menschen die einfach Ihre
Ukraine Politik halt sehr polemisch
kritisieren
zurückzugewinnen und heißt das auch dass
sie mit dem Kriegstreiber Putin
eigentlich nicht mehr sprechen werden
weil das ja ein sehr kategorischer
harter Ton war eigentlich das waren
jetzt ja doch eine ganze Reihe von
Fragen in diesem Zusammenhang ansonsten
sind alle Varianten in denen ich Ihnen
begegne ich
das ist eben ein bisschen facettenreich
und was glaube ich der ein oder andere
manchmal übersehen hat dass meine
Lebenslauf lernen als Politiker ja doch
eher als versammlungsredner begonnen hat
und nicht so wie sie sich oft kennen mit
Texten die ich geordnet vortragen und
deshalb weiß ich wie es geht und es gibt
dann auch glaube ich eine Sache die man
sehr klar sein muss wenn der Leute
hingehen und meine Veranstaltung wo ganz
viele kommen und zuzuhören sprengen
wollen oder lernen durch unglaubliche
Beleidigung auch gestisch in eine Art
und Weise die man nicht nett finden muss
dann gibt es ja viele Wege damit
umzugehen aber einer ist sofort
zurückzulangen und das hatte ich mir
fest vorgenommen ich habe gesagt wenn
ich rede dann warte ich gar nicht erst
ab sondern ich spreche das gleich direkt
an und das haben sie denn gesehen wie
ich das mache wenn ich das direkt
anspreche was die Frage betrifft rechne
ich damit dass man andere überzeugen
kann das muss man in der Demokratie
immer und deshalb
kann auch jeder damit rechnen dass wenn
Sie meine Veranstaltung besuchen und
eine Frage stellen oder auch ihre
Meinung da darstellen dass ich antworte
ich habe auch manche erlebt die das
auch aus so einer politischen
Perspektive heraus tun die völlig
überrascht sind dass sie beamt an der
Antwort kriegen und nicht einfach nur
beschimpft werden was für welche sie
wohl sind aber manche sind dann
überrascht dass die Antwort
eben gute Gründe hat warum wir zum
Beispiel jetzt die Ukraine unterstützen
und warum Russlands Angriff auf die
Ukraine auch Frieden und Sicherheit
bedroht für uns alle weil damit die
Grundstrukturen unser
friedensarchitektur in Europa bedroht
sind was Willy Brandt und Helmut Schmidt
erreicht haben mit der KSZE und der OSZE
heute das war ein großer Prozess der
auch den Teil des Eisernen Vorhangs und
unsere deutsche Einheit mit möglicht hat
und der diese Prinzipien die Putin jetzt
mit Füßen tritt zur Grundlage hatte das
glaube ich muss immer dazu gesagt werden
sondern war noch die dritte ja genau
natürlich
selbstverständlich auch mal wieder mit
ihnen reden kann
aber da ist nichts terminiert falls es
gleich nachfragen
die nächste Frage hat Herr Papa
sie haben in Vilnius eine Reihe von
bilateralen Gesprächen und sie sind mit
den türkischen Präsidenten
getroffen und auch mit dem griechischen
Ministerpräsidenten deutschland hat in
der Vergangenheit schon
vermittelt und die Spannungen in die
hygien
Mittelmeer abzubauen was war oder was
ist Ihr Anliegen bei diesem Gespräch
gewesen und haben sie erreicht dass sie
gewollt haben
könnte die Antwort kurz machen ja aber
ich sag doch noch ein paar Bemerkung mir
ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass wir
unseren Beitrag dazu leisten dass die
Beziehung zum Beispiel
zwischen der Türkei und der EU und der
Türkei und Deutschland sich gut
weiterentwickeln das gilt
selbstverständlich für die Beziehung die
wir mit Griechenland haben wir sind
beide EU-Mitglieder und haben viele
viele gemeinsame Perspektiven und
Ansichten und deshalb sind meine
Gespräche mit dem griechischen
Ministerpräsidenten jetzt schon seit
vielen Jahren immer sehr
freundschaftlich was ich auch sehr
wichtig finde und wir fühlen uns auch
verpflichtet für ein gutes Verhältnis
der Beteiligten in der Ägäis zu sorgen
und sind da immer wieder Partner und das
werden wir auch sein und bleiben und
natürlich hat das eine Rolle gespielt
ich habe für mich das so wahrgenommen
dass beide Regierungschefs also dass der
Präsident und der
Ministerpräsident sehr wohl die
Perspektive haben ein besseres
Verhältnis der beiden Länder zueinander
möglich zu machen und das wäre doch gut
die nächste Frage hat Herr Schmidt
es ist das weiße Mikro
Herr Bundeskanzler Europa und
Deutschland haben sich haben die
Transformation gestartet weg von Kohle
Gas und Öl sie haben es schon ausgeführt
international wird weiter massiv in die
fossilen investiert auch von westlichen
Konzernen die Exportländer wollen nicht
aussteigen was macht sie eigentlich
zuversichtlich dass das CO2 was in
Europa eingespart wird nicht noch ja
jahrzehntelang in anderen Teilen der
Welt imitiert wird und Europa sich und
seine Industrie tatsächlich auch ein
Stück weit belastet ohne dass wirklich
was für das Klima gewonnen ist
das ist eine Frage die uns alle
umtreiben muss die ist schon von sehr
grundlegender Bedeutung und deshalb ein
paar Antworten darauf
wir müssen wollen und wünschen dass die
Länder in Südamerikas in Afrika und in
Asien
einen ähnlichen wirtschaftlichen
Wohlstand entwickeln können wie wir ihn
haben
und wenn man die ökonomischen
Entwicklung der letzten Jahrzehnte
betrachtet dann ist das zwar ja gerade
unsere gegenwärtigen
bricht unser diese Woche zuletzt
verhandelter Bericht über die
Entwicklungsziele gezeigt hat nicht
überall gut aber es hat doch Milliarden
gegeben die irgendwie vorangekommen sind
ökonomisch viele die jetzt in diesen
Ländern zur Mittelschicht dazu gehören
und es gibt ökonomische
Wachstumsprozesse die sehr enorm sind
als Folge auch der Globalisierung
aber wenn wir uns klar machen dass wir
das wollen und wünschen müssen dass dort
ein ähnlicher Wohlstand herrscht wie wir
ihn haben ist klar wenn das alles so
geschieht wie wir das die letzten 200
Jahre gemacht haben dann geht das schief
nicht nur für diese Länder sondern auch
für uns also hat Deutschland hat Europa
haben wir eine ganz herausragende
Aufgabe nämlich die Technologien zu
entwickeln mit denen man
wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand organisieren
kann ohne das Klima und Biodiversität zu
schädigen das ist unsere Aufgabe und
indem wir das bei uns machen geben wir
auch gleich eine Antwort wie man es
anderswo machen kann und wenn ich jetzt
mit vielen spreche habe ich den Eindruck
das wird schon verstanden und es ist
etwas
wichtig ist dass die 250 260 für sich
als Ziel wo sie klimaneutral wollen auch
akzeptiert haben für mich ist aber genau
um die Frage zu adressieren die Sie
angesprochen haben die Initiative so
wichtig gewesen jetzt immer mehr Erfolg
hat ein internationalen klimaklub zu
schaffen das habe ich ja schon als
Finanzminister begonnen und das ist
jetzt bei den G7 vereinbart mit
unglaublich vielen anderen Ländern die
da regelmäßig jetzt dazu kommen mit
Chile haben wir jetzt den co-vorsitz
damit das nicht so eine G7 Veranstaltung
ist aber da sind jetzt beigetreter kommt
immer mehr
Australien gerade als bei dem Besuch den
der australischen Ministerpräsident bei
mir hatte
und das ist die Antwort wie wir
gleichzeitig diese Probleme lösen das
andere dann noch Konkurrenz machen mit
schmutziger Technologie
da kann man dann die Antwort geben mit
Zahlen oder ganz Ausgleich Mechanismen
gemacht hat und andere auch machen aber
muss gleichzeitig eine
transformationsperspektive formulieren
und das ist das was ich mir mit dem
Thema Kopf verbinde da werden wir nicht
immer alle die gleichen Politiken haben
aber solange wir auf dem gleichen Pfad
unterwegs sind wird es gehen und
das wird uns noch ein bisschen
beschäftigen aber ich glaube dass wir
sogar einen großen zusätzlichen
Wachstumsschub bekommen können denn wenn
das erstmal gezeigt wird dass das geht
dass die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der
Welt
Industrieland weltweit wettbewerbsfähig
sein kann mit modernsten Technologien
aber das Klima und die Biodiversität
nicht schädigt dann werden das alle
anderen machbar wollen und sie werden
dabei Zurückgreifen auf Fähigkeiten die
wir hier dann entwickelt haben nämlich
die Technologien und das ist dann auch
ein gutes Modell für das
exportorientierte Deutschland
wir haben jetzt gleich anderthalb
Stunden herum die Frageliste ist noch
sehr lang wie viele wissen die noch
nicht dran waren ich würde mal versuchen
dass wir noch fünf fragestellerinnen und
Fragesteller schaffen mit kurzen Fragen
und kurzen Antworten
auch nur acht Stunden
danke schön
[Musik]
Bundeskanzler ich habe eine Frage die
das Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland und
Israel im weiteren Sinne betrifft
ich gehe davon aus dass ihnen der Name
Muriel Asseburg etwas sagt ein
Wissenschaftlerin mit Expertise für den
Nahen Osten die seit vielen Jahren für
die Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
arbeitet einer der wichtigen beratenden
Think Tanks der Bundesregierung sie hat
in einem längeren Interview auch
bestimmte Handlung der israelischen
Regierung in dem Besatzungsgebieten
kritisiert daraufhin gab es eine starke
öffentliche Kampagne in der unter
anderem die israelische Botschaft sich
zu Wort meldete und davon sprach das ist
Antisemitismus im
pseudo-akademischen Milieu gäbe lässt
sich die Bundesregierung beraten von
Antisemiten im pseudoakademischen Milieu
also um die abstrakte Frage zu
beantworten die ja von jeder Person
völlig frei ist selbstverständlich nicht
dann möchte ich gerne konkret nachfragen
wie gesagt davon ausgehen dass ihnen die
causa-asser Burg und die
Äußerungen und den Streit um ihre
Personen geläufig sind wir bewerten sie
es dass die Botschaft eines Landes in
derartig scharfer Form Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen
öffentlich kritisiert das hatte dann
unter anderem zur Folge das Straßburg
jetzt bei einem Besuch in Israel tätlich
angegriffen wurde
wie bewerten sie es dass diplomatische
Vertretungen so agieren
das würde ich ich will gar nicht
bewerten was da gemacht wird das habe
ich in der Vergangenheit nicht getan und
auch hier nicht
ich glaube dass die Haltung der
Bundesregierung in dieser in all diesen
Fragen sehr klar ist aber ich will jetzt
auch nicht den Eindruck erwecken als ich
als ob ich weil ich da zwei
Zeitungsmeldung drüber gelesen habe
jetzt angefangen habe Texte
nachzuverfolgen und zu studieren ich
habe gar keine ich weiß gar nicht was da
alles steht und das geht wahrscheinlich
die meisten anderen hier im Raum auch so
vermutlich jedenfalls
herr Steiner hat die nächste Frage
ist auch das richtige Mikrofon hier
vorne in der Mitte
wir sind jetzt knapp auf der Hälfte der
Legislatur fehlende Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher kaputte Schulen fehlen des
Pflegepersonal ihre Wohnungs neubauziele
sind weit verfehlt vier bis fünf
Windräder pro Tag sind auch noch nicht
erreicht damit Pumpen und Sanierung sind
für viele teure Zukunftsmusik die Bürger
spielen stattdessen Inflation steigende
Zinsen mieten und Lebensmittelpreise und
wirtschaftlich kommt man ein Rezession
als Bundeskanzler ist natürlich
vergleichsweise leicht fünf gerade sein
zu lassen dieses eben gesagt haben mit
dem geleisteten vielleicht auch
zufrieden zu sein und Gelassenheit im
Miteinander zu fordern ganz flexibel und
pragmatisch aber in relevanten Teilen
der Bevölkerung ist die Stimmung ja
offenkundig eine deutlich andere nicht
nur bei den böswilligen die Leute sind
massiv verunsichert oder sie sagen hier
jetzt setzen
natürlich werden die Preise für fossile
Energien wahrscheinlich steigen das ist
ein Satz bei dem viele Bürger jetzt
wieder sagen werden was will er uns denn
damit jetzt gesagt haben ich würde gerne
von Ihnen wissen wann kommt denn jetzt
die Führung die sie mal versprochen
haben wenn sie bestellt wurde
ich habe am Anfang sehr umfassend
dargestellt wie sehr geführt wird und
das Deutschland sich in der größten
modernisierungs- und innovationsperiode
befindet seit vielen vielen Jahrzehnten
das ist auch notwendig wenn wir eine
leistungsfähige Volkswirtschaft mit
guten Arbeitsplätzen sein wollen und
CO2-neutral Wirtschaften wollen 2045
schon das sind von jetzt an 22 Jahre
also das ist jetzt keine lange das ist
das ist jetzt nicht lange hin insofern
bin ich sehr dafür dass wir uns sehr
klar machen wie groß die Aufgabe ist
aber bin auch sehr hinterher dass wir so
wie wir das mit dem Tempo in den letzten
Monaten und im letzten Jahr in diesem
Jahr geschafft haben auch weitermachen
damit das tatsächlich gelingt und darauf
können sich auch alle verlassen ich bin
überzeugt dass wir eine leistungsfähige
Volkswirtschaft mit guten Arbeitsplätzen
bleiben werden
dann noch ganz kurze Nachfrage viele
Leute haben gefragt Richtlinienkompetenz
des Kanzlers wo ist die denn wann wird
sie benutzt ich würde gerne wissen wie
es dir Brief zur Kindergrundsicherung zu
interpretieren war das eine Anwendung
ihrer Richtlinienkompetenz oder war das
nur eine freundliche Aufforderung an die
beteiligten Ministerien als sich das mal
davor von meiner richtlinienkonferenz
gebraucht macht hat war das auch ein
höflicher freundlicher Brief der wurde
ja öffentlich bekannt und das ist ja
vielleicht auch ein guter Stil aber in
der Sache gehe ich davon aus dass das
was ich dort
aufgeschrieben habe auch kommt nämlich
dass wir das Gesetz Ende August fertig
haben
in der Mitte schlecht zu sehen
ihr eingangstatement begonnen mit der
zeitenwände und dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine es hat
jetzt in den letzten anderthalb Stunden
nicht die dominante Rolle gespielt
inwiefern gehen Sie davon aus dass der
Erfolg in allen anderen Bereichen die
sie genannt hat vom Erfolg der Ukraine
im Krieg gegen Russland ausgeht und
inwiefern hängt der Erfolg ihrer
Kanzlerschaft vom Erfolg der Ukraine
als Mensch als Bürger
als Deutscher als Europäer wünsche ich
mir dass die Ukraine Erfolg hat und das
muss ich gar nicht erst mit meinem Amt
verbinden das ist ein Anliegen dass wir
alle haben sollten denn wir können nicht
hinnehmen und auch nicht uns damit
abfinden dass in so grausamer und
brutaler Weise das Völkerrecht mit Füßen
getreten wird
Nachfrage haben Sie das Gefühl man
müsste noch mehr tun um der Ukraine zu
helfen oder ist das was bisher getan
wird auch an Waffenhilfe einfach das was
geht und
das versteht nicht man aber in der
Qualität wird mehr nicht gehen für die
Ukraine
wir haben ja sehr viel gemacht und das
was wir tun ist auch sehr relevant
sowohl was die Luft Verteidigung
betrifft als auch die Artillerie was die
Ausbildung betrifft was die Schaffung
von
Reparatur Strukturen betrifft damit die
gelieferten Waffen und nicht nur unsere
auch eingesetzt werden können das
Ausbauen von Kapazitäten zum
munitionsproduktion auch das gehört ja
dazu und wir sind jetzt unverändert und
auch immer weiter dabei dafür zu sorgen
dass die Ukraine so lange durchhalten
kann wie das erforderlich ist
Herr Scholz ihre Regierungszeit ist dann
fast genau zwei Jahren eventuell vorbei
wie wollen Sie
denn auch wie wollen Sie dass man sich
dann an sie erinnert Olaf Scholz soll
der Kanzler sein der
Anfang meiner Tätigkeit als
Bundeskanzler und deshalb bin der Frage
wie man sie hinterher zusammenfassen
soll nicht beschäftigt und ob ich es
einmal tun werde weiß ich nicht das
müssen dann doch schon andere wissen
aber ich glaube wir sind schon in einem
Moment
der sehr bedeutendes für die Geschichte
und geschickt würde das Gescheitere
geschickt unseres Landes
die sicherheitsagentur Europas
zerstört hat
dass man immer denkt die Politik die wir
machen das ist doch die Zeiten wenn wir
aber das ist ja nur eine Konsequenz
daraus trotzdem sind wir in einem Moment
wo wir es jetzt schaffen müssen die
Grundlage dafür zu legen dass
Deutschland eine Gesellschaft ist die
vorne dabei ist wenn es um Technologien
geht die auch in 10 20 30 Jahren sehr
gute Arbeitsplätze hat die
wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand hat und die
zusammenhält und die ist gleichzeitig
schafft Klima und wir Universität zu
schützen und in dem Sinne bin ich der
Überzeugung dass wir da
auf dem richtigen Weg sind und dass wir
das Tempo
losgelegt hat mit dem Tempo losgelegt
haben dass da zu erforderlich ist ist ja
schon nachgefragt worden wenn man so
Ziele hat was man alles erreichen will
dann fragen ja einige zwei Minuten
später und schon erreicht aber wir sind
ja dabei und kriegen das hin dass wir
auch tatsächlich so eine Geschwindigkeit
erreichen wie ich sie formuliere mit
fünf bis sechs Windräder am Tag und so
weiter das müssen wir hinkriegen und
mein Eindruck ist das ist uns gelungen
und dann dürfen wir jetzt nicht
nachlassen weil es für die Zukunft
unseres Landes von so großer Bedeutung
ist
Herr Busch mit der nächsten Frage
danke Fabian Busch von web.de und GMX
ähm Herr Bundeskanzler im Mai hat der
Bundestag eine Pflegereform beschlossen
über die eigentlich alle Redner gesagt
haben auch aus ihrer Koalition das wird
nicht reichen was wollen sie noch
unternehmen um die Pflegeversicherung so
aufzustellen dass sie in 10 oder 20
Jahren noch funktioniert
wir müssen eine gute Pflege haben in
Deutschland das sind viele inhaltliche
und fachlichere Formen wie die Regierung
weiter vorantreiben wird und wir müssen
natürlich immer auch die Finanzierung
gewährleisten und deshalb gehört ja zu
dieser Reform und den Reformschritten
die wir uns vorgenommen haben dass wir
auch die Belastung die die Bürger und
Bürger die zum Beispiel in stationärer
Pflege sind Stück für Stück reduzieren
wollen da gibt es so eine abwärtstreppe
wie Sie wissen und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass genügend Frauen und Männer
sich für den Berufe entscheiden und dort
auch tätig sind das ist ja eine ganz
große Herausforderung wenn wir uns das
einmal anschauen die
Fluktuation in den Pflegeberufen ist
ziemlich groß also da lernen Leute viele
Jahre einen schweren Beruf und dann
bleiben sie ich habe die Zeit jetzt
nicht genau im Kopf 8 bis 9 Jahre glaube
ich also sagen wir mal acht im Schnitt
da und wechseln dann den Beruf und das
wäre ja schon schön wenn wir die
Arbeitsbedingungen so gestalten können
dass viele darin auch bleiben ein paar
Fortschritte haben wir schon
durchgesetzt
Hubertus Heil und ich sogar schon in der
letzten Legislaturperiode das zum
Beispiel Tarifverträge eine größere
Rolle spielen dafür die bescheidzahlung
der Beschäftigten und die Löhne die
damit verbunden sind aber das ist nicht
alles das geht auch schon um gute und
familienfreundliche Arbeitsbedingungen
was sehr schwer ist wenn Pflege ständig
zur Verfügung stehen muss also für mich
ein Thema bei dem wir auch nicht
nachlassen dürfen und dann können Sie
auch darauf verlassen werden wir nicht
schaffen wir drei letzte Fragen
dann haben wir nämlich den Kollegen dort
hinten Herrn Eier und Frau Pauli zuerst
ihren Namen kenne ich nicht ja Alexander
schönen ProSieben Sat.1 Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben vor ja ein paar
Tagen in einem Interview gesagt dass sie
nicht John Wayne sein welche Filmfigur
würde zu Ihnen passen
die Frage könnte ich beantworten mache
ich aber nicht
kann eine Nachfrage mit Blick jetzt nach
der Sommerpause mit ihren
Koalitionspartnern wie werden sie denn
dort umgehen mit Blick auf die ganzen
streitigkeiten werden sie mehr Macht
Worte sprechen mehr moderieren
mein Eindruck ist dass alle
das jetzt durchaus als ein Moment
begreifen wo sie die Tatsache dass wir
so viel abgearbeitet haben bei dem was
sie jetzt noch vor uns haben
weniger laut aber weiter mit Ergebnissen
zustande bringen werden und die sollen
dann auch schneller kommen und ich
glaube das wird uns auch gelingt
wunderschön
in Deutschland
zu verstehen
die einen hohen Respekt vor den
unterschiedlichen religiösen
Vorstellungen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
haben und dass das uns auch als
Gesellschaft auszeichnet
und deshalb müssen wir umso strenger
sein mit denjenigen die Gewalt zum
Beispiel ausüben oder antisemitisch
agieren oder Anti muslimisch agieren
oder antichristlich gibt ja alles und
eine Gesellschaft die Zusammenhalt muss
tatsächlich von der Vorstellung von
im weitesten Sinne guter Toleranz
ausgehen
es ist eine Nachfrage eine Nachfrage bei
Ihnen überall falsche Frage bitte
aufhören Politik
die Vereinbarung war Nachfrage neues
Thema wir haben echt zeitnöte vor pauli
möchte noch eine Frage stellen und da
hinten ist ein Kollege der mich sehr
strafend ansieht weil ich die nämlich
vergessen habe bislang tut mir leid
jetzt jetzt
noch mal vielleicht auf eine Bilanz
vielleicht nicht sozusagen ihrer
einmaligen Regierungszeit aber jetzt das
vergangenen Jahres wir haben über ihre
Erfolge oder Sie haben über ihre Erfolge
eingangs gesprochen wir haben viel über
die AFD gesprochen die nicht nur der SPD
sondern der Ampel insgesamt und der
Demokratie sicherlich Schwierigkeiten
bereitet den kritischen Bürger der sich
von den ampelparteien abwendet wie
würden Sie ihm oder was würden Sie ihm
sagen was waren die besonderen Erfolge
dieses Jahres und was
wo sind sie sehr kritisch in diesem
kleinen intimen Rahmen
was muss dringend besser werden wo muss
müssen Sie noch einen Zahn zulegen
ich will mich mit dem ersten Teil
aufhalten aber um es klar zu sagen
es ist doch schon ein Erfolg
dass im Herbst des letzten Jahres alle
große Angst hatten dass wir es kalt
haben werden das unglaublich viele
Fabriken schließen müssen dass wir eine
Wirtschaftskrise erleben die zehn Jahre
dauert
und dass wir jetzt da sind und völlig
vergessen haben dass wir dann Probleme
hatten das ist irgendwie wenn man sich
so viel Mühe gegeben hat so weit zu
kommen etwas nur immer denkt
was sage ich eigentlich dazu aber
eigentlich sage ich toll denn es
bedeutet ja dass an uns eine ganz große
Krise vorbei gegangen ist das haben wir
wirklich geschafft und wenn man sich
noch mal umhört was damals gesagt wurde
nicht nur hierzulande sondern auch
weltweit eigentlich hat niemand geglaubt
dass wir das
bewältigen haben wir aber und das finde
ich erstmal einen guten Erfolg und nun
könnte ich das was ich eingangs gesagt
habe wiederholen das macht keinen Sinn
aber das war mir schon sehr wichtig und
ich glaube dass ich da niemanden zu nahe
trete wenn ich sage
es hilft wenn man wenn man weiß dass man
sich sowieso einigt das auch immer zum
Ausdruck bringt
eine allerletzte Frage wenn Sie Zeit
haben von Frank Jordans
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler vor zwei
Jahren sind bei der Flut im Alter
sind bei der Flut im Ahrtal uns in der
Region mehr als 200 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen die EU-Kommission wird in 15
juli als Tag des Gedenkens für
Opfer der Klimakrise
benennen und begehen in Deutschland
selbst
spricht man irgendwie weniger über die
klimatoten vor der Haustür als über
verspätete Ferienflieger und
ja den heizhammer meine Frage ist warum
schaffen das andere Länder bei
Tempolimit oder
kurzstreckenflugverbot oder auch Einbau
von
Wärmepumpen so viel schneller als
Deutschland ihre Regierung scheint sich
da im kleinen irgendwie zu verhindern
und
dann am Ende kommt viel
weniger raus als reingehen
Teile die Analyse nicht ich glaube dass
die Themen die sie gerade aufgerufen
haben ihr zu dem kleinen der großen
Herausforderungen gehören die wichtig
sind wenn wir die Klimakrise bekämpfen
wollen und dass die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt das schafft
2045 CO2 neutral zu wirtschaften und
gleichzeitig weiter vorne dabei zu sein
und großes Wirtschaftswachstum zu haben
und gut bezahlte Arbeitsplätze das ist
groß groß
keine Nachfrage wenn ich darf die aber
in ihrer eigenen Koalition wird ja teils
mit Desinformationen gearbeitet was die
Pläne der Bundesregierung angeht ist da
nicht irgendwann der Punkt gekommen wo
sie
bei den reichsbürgern mal auf den Putz
hauen oder die sprichwörtliche Besucher
rausholen
ich kann ihn versichern dass wir in der
Koalition viel diskutieren aber das
niemand sehr eine so heftige Rede dem
anderen gegenüber vor hat oder jemals
hatte
ich weiß dass einige Fragen noch
unbeantwortet sind und übrig geblieben
sind und bitte um Verständnis dass wir
jetzt trotzdem einen Punkt setzen müssen
weil der Kanzler einen Anschluss Termin
hat das heißt nur Herr Bundeskanzler sie
sind jederzeit hier wieder herzlich
willkommen gerne auch vor dem Zeitpunkt
in einem Jahr danke dass Sie gekommen
sind und damit schließe ich die
Pressekonferenz schön Urlaub
ja da sind wir wieder nach einer
ziemlich langen
sommerpressekonferenz wurden ziemlich
viele Fragen gestellt so ganz
verschiedenen Themenbereichen ich
spreche jetzt mit Nicole Diekmann kurz
noch mal über die wichtigsten Punkte
dieser eine Stunde 40 Pressekonferenz
und Nicole ist mir jetzt hier wieder aus
dem Hauptstadtstudio zugeschaltet hi da
bin ich wieder ja Nicole was bleibt dir
denn am meisten hängen nach dieser
sommerpressekonferenz außer der Jingle
Bells Klingelton genau das Handy das
Fotografen ich glaube es war ein
Fotograf das nicht mehr aufhören wollte
zu klingeln ähm interessant waren zwei
Punkte finde ich erstens ein Olaf Scholz
der wirklich wahnsinnig gelassen wirkte
es ist natürlich immer die Zielsetzung
des oder derjenigen in den Jahren vor
2022 war es ja lange Angela Merkel die
diese sommerpressekonferenzen besucht
hat auf Einladung der
Bundespressekonferenz es ist natürlich
immer Ziel locker zu wirken das ist Olaf
Scholz tatsächlich gelungen das ist das
eine und das zweite ist die andere Seite
die Journalisten meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es waren tatsächlich viele
Fragen zu vielen Themen ich sag mal quer
durch den Garten vor einem Jahr war das
vorherrschende Thema natürlich der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine der herrscht
immer noch war auch Thema aber
nicht in der Dominanz in der er es im
vergangenen Jahr war
ich gucke ja auch mal so ein bisschen in
meine Aufzeichnung es war ja wirklich
unglaublich viele Themen es ging relativ
zu Anfang auch mal um diesen ampelzoff
mit dem wir uns hier ja auch jetzt
beschäftigen und Olaf Scholz hat das ja
irgendwie ganz pragmatisch verpackt und
hat gesagt na ja ähm wir diskutieren
halt bloß früher nur feste Standpunkte
gibt wie glaubhaft ist das für dich wenn
er quasi diesen ampelzopf so ein
bisschen als gesunde Diskussionskultur
verkauft genau und auch als Spiegelbild
der Gesellschaft ne das ist ja schon
seit längerem narrativ das soll er im
übrigen auch ähm Mittwoch also
vorgestern Abend beim
Koalitionsausschuss noch mal ähm so
zusammengefasst haben ja Leute Wir
streiten hier viel es hat wirklich viel
zu oft gegeben aber wie sollte es anders
sein also es ist quasi alternativlos in
diesen Zeiten für die ja eben seine
Regierung die große gesellschaftliche
Transformation ausgerufen hat
natürlich ist es ähm Aufgabe Job eines
bundeskanz dass davon auszugehen seine
Wählerinnen und Wähler und auch alle
anderen davon ausgehen zu lassen dass er
das Kind schon schaukeln wird deswegen
ist immer interessant wo es dann wo er
es dann doch nicht hundertprozentig
durchhält wo dann die unbedachten
Augenblicke sind die kleinen Löcher in
der Argumentation und das kam später da
ging es gar nicht mehr und das
sogenannte heizungsgesetz und das GEG
ist war glaube ich die zweite Frage in
der Pressekonferenz die dann eben auf
diesen großen Streit diese Zerreißprobe
in der Ampel angespielt hatte er wurde
später in einem ganz anderen
Zusammenhang nach Gesetzesvorhaben nach
Innovation gefragt und da habe ich mir
was aufgeschrieben und zwar rutschte ihm
dann raus
bevor wir daraus ein Gesetzesvorschlag
machen diskutieren wir das ganz
ordentlich bis wir das alles verstehen
und das war ähm im Kontext im
Unterschied zum heizungsgesetz von ihm
gemeint also die Faktor hat Scholz in
dem Moment gesagt beim heizungsgesetz
haben wir es genauso nicht gemacht
daraus haben wir gelernt das machen wir
demnächst anders also ganz so toll ganz
so quasi ähm alternativlos wie ich eben
schon gesagt habe war das sicherlich
nicht was ich diese Ampel mit dieser
Diskussion mit dieser Debattenkultur mit
diesen Umgang miteinander im
Zusammenhang mit dem Gehege geleistet
hat
zur Stimmung in der Ampelkoalition gibt
es auch einige User-Kommentare hier
schreibt zum Beispiel jemand auf Youtube
ich glaube das Scholz bald die Koalition
beendet für wie realistisch hältst du
denn dass diese Koalition zerbrechen
könnte also man kann eine Koalition
nicht einfach so beenden das ist schon
mal das eine da gibt es ganz klare
verfassungsrechtliche Vorgaben
selbst also warum sollte er das ist die
eine Frage warum sollte Scholz diese
Koalition beenden im Gegenteil Schweiz
hat vorhin noch gesagt er stehe quasi am
Anfang seiner Kanzlerschaft der ist wild
entschlossen auch daran dass er heute
mehrfach keinen Zweifel in zwei Jahren
wieder anzutreten als Kanzlerkandidat
das bedeutet natürlich nicht automatisch
wir leben hier in der Demokratie dass er
dann auch Kanzler wird aber er will es
werden warum noch mal auch mit Blick auf
die Werte der AFD und mit Blick der
wirklich miesen Werte der ampelparteien
die gerade keine Mehrheit mehr zustande
kriegen würden warum sollte Scholz diese
Koalition beenden da wäre er schön doof
es ging neben diesem ampelzoff ja auch
in Teilen um die AFD und da hat Scholz
ein Satz gesagt an dem man ihm später
eigentlich ganz gut messen könnte oder
ja und das finde ich relativ mutig
Scholz hat gesagt er geht davon aus dass
die AFD bei der Bundestagswahl 2025
nicht großartig anders abschneiden wird
als sie es 2021 getan hat da lag sie
wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung
habe bei 11 und ein paar Prozent
im Moment steht sie wir haben es ja
vorhin ganz zu Beginn unserer Sendung
einmal kurz gesehen im Politbarometer
von heute da steht sie bei 20%. das wäre
also fast eine Halbierung und da sind
wir bei einem anderen Mann da sind wir
bei Friedrich Merz dem Chef der CDU und
auch der Unionsfraktion Friedrich Merz
als er angetreten ist um sich zum
Vorsitzenden der CDU wählen zu lassen
hat er unter an unter anderem
versprochen die AFD zu halbieren da lag
die noch nicht bei 20 %. sondern bei um
die 14 15 %. das ist bei ihm also nicht
gelungen und ich kann mir vorstellen
dass Friedrich Merz ist überhaupt nicht
freut dass er jetzt permanent mit diesem
seinem Versprechen konfrontiert wird
aber natürlich ist es auch unsere
Aufgabe in danach noch mal zu fragen und
ähm ja ich habe mich vorhin gefragt beim
zuschauen ob Friedrich Merz Olaf Scholz
dazu geraten hätte sich heute soweit aus
dem Fenster zu gehen denn das ist gerade
gesagt die Aussage steht die und daran
wird er sich messen lassen müssen
und das werden wir hier sicher auch zur
nächsten Bundestagswahl wieder tun ich
habe hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community an dich und zwar fragt Sven
Odendahl hat Scholz denn auf eine Frage
wirklich konkret geantwortet es war doch
viel dabei wo er den Fragen ausgewichen
ist und einfach andere Themen aufgemacht
hat oder war das nur mein Eindruck nö
das hat er schon getan ich habe das ja
auch zu Beginn schon gesagt die große
Frage heute ist wird er wieder Scholzen
wie man das hier so schön sagt also die
Fragen so ein bisschen abperlen lassen
es gibt immer ein gutes Indiz an dem man
merkt die Frage passt ihm jetzt nicht da
will er nicht so ganz drauf eingehen
dann bedankt er sich nämlich die Frage
für die Frage bei dem oder der Frage
stellen denn vielen Dank für Ihre Frage
lautet das dann
nein auf viele Fragen ist ja tatsächlich
nicht konkret eingegangen da ist mir
besonders im Gedächtnis geblieben die
USA liefern Träume Munition an die
Ukraine das kam letztes Wochenende kam
die Nachricht und da wurde er von einem
Kollegen gefragt ob Deutschland wie
Deutschland das eigentlich laut
Verträgen tun müssen als ein Staat ähm
der die Streumunition den Einsatz von
Munition echtet versucht habe auf die
USA einzuwirken den Präsidenten Joe
Biden davon abzubringen Streu Munition
an die Ukraine zu liefern auf diese
Frage und auch auf andere hat Olaf
Scholz ganz konkret nicht geantwortet
Nicole ich danke dir dass du so lange
mit uns dran geblieben bist und dass du
unsere Fragen beantwortet hast vielen
Dank und bis bald wie immer sehr gerne
bis bald
ja und an die die noch dabei sind jetzt
nach einer Stunde 45
Pressekonferenz von Olaf Scholz vielen
Dank dass ihr dabei wart ich darf zum
Schluss noch mal kurz einen Blick in die
Stimmung bei euch hier schreibt jemand
Olaf labert seit der Bundeskanzler ist
nur rum Wasser alles machen will und
wird bis jetzt kam halt nichts also eine
sehr unzufriedene Stimme von euch hier
schreibt aber auch jemand stabiler
Auftritt kennt man so gar nicht von
Scholz er hat eine coole ist heute am
Start die man gerne öfter sehen möchte
und dann sagt noch jemand auf Youtube
ich bin der Meinung bei so einer
schwierigen Lage in der Welt die wir
haben bin ich mit unserer Regierung sehr
zufrieden ja eure Reaktion auf diese
Pressekonferenz also gut durchmischt
danke für eure Fragen und für eure
Kommentare ich freue mich aufs nächste
Mal mit euch bei ZDF heute live